This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. For thousands of years, poets and musicians have celebrated the arrival of love. Songs like, At Last, talk about the long-awaited moment when a soulmate says yes, and the doors of heaven open. But while musicians preach the melodies of love, and manuals teach people how to fall in love, there is much less advice about how we should think, feel, and act at the end of relationships.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。几千年来，诗人和音乐家一直在歌颂爱情的到来。像《终于》这样的歌曲讲述了当灵魂伴侣说出“我愿意”时那期待已久的时刻，天堂之门也随之敞开。然而，尽管音乐家们宣扬爱的旋律，恋爱手册也教人们如何坠入爱河，但关于我们在关系的尽头该如何思考、感受和行事的建议却少得多。
Today, we bring you the conclusion of our month-long series about love. Our focus over the past few weeks has been on what comes after the euphoric buzz of new infatuation has worn off. We've explored how to better understand our partners and how to be better understood. We've talked about acceptance and apologies, and how to let go of our annoyances and frustrations with the people we love. Today, though, we're going to look at what happens when rifts between partners are too wide to bridge. We're going to talk about the psychology of breakups.
今天，我们为您带来为期一个月的爱情系列的尾声。过去几周，我们的关注点一直集中在新的迷恋带来的欣快感消退之后会发生什么。我们探讨了如何更好地理解伴侣以及如何被更好地理解。我们讨论了接纳和道歉，以及如何放下对所爱之人的恼怒和沮丧。不过，今天我们要探讨的是，当伴侣之间的裂痕大到无法弥合时会发生什么。我们将探讨分手的心理学。
We'll examine the most common mistakes we make when it comes to splitting up, and explore techniques that can help us do better. How to Set the Past to Rest This week on Hidden Brain Any. Any aspiring novelist will tell you that it's easy to start a story and very hard to bring it to a close. The same is true.
我们将审视分手时最常犯的错误，并探讨能帮助我们做得更好的技巧。如何让过去安息 本周《隐藏的大脑》任意。任何有抱负的小说家都会告诉你，开始一个故事很容易，但要给它画上句号却很难。事实也的确如此。
in real life, as most of us have discovered. Navigating the conclusion of a relationship with someone we loved and who once loved us is not simple. Antonio Pasquale-Leoni is a psychologist at the University of Windsor in Canada. He studies the emotions we feel around these complicated events and how they shape our behavior. Antonio Pasquois-Leoni, welcome to Hidden Brain.
正如我们大多数人所发现的那样，在现实生活中也是如此。如何度过与我们曾爱过、且曾经爱过我们的人的感情终点并不简单。安东尼奥·帕斯夸莱-莱奥尼是加拿大温莎大学的心理学家。他研究我们在这些复杂事件中感受到的情绪以及它们如何塑造我们的行为。安东尼奥·帕斯夸莱-莱奥尼，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。
Thank you so much for having me, Shanker. Antonio, as a young man in your late teens, and 20s, you were an aspiring actor. I understand that you also like to write poetry. You must have cut quite a romantic figure. It depends what you call romantic, but yeah, I started as a, I wasn't sure if I wanted to study biology and go to medicine or if I wanted to go into theater. I ended up going into theater and somehow ended up in a compromise, which I think is psychology. And, you know, many years later, I sort of realized that there's something that happens on stage. An actor generates an emotional experience on stage for the entertainment of the audience.
非常感谢邀请我来，尚卡尔。安东尼奥，在你十几岁晚期和二十多岁的时候，你曾是一个有抱负的演员。据我了解，你还喜欢写诗。你当年一定是个挺浪漫的人吧。这取决于你对浪漫的定义，不过是的，我最初，我当时不确定是想学生物学去从医，还是想进戏剧界。我最后进了戏剧界，不知怎么的，最终成了一种折衷，我认为那就是心理学。而且，你知道，多年以后，我某种程度上意识到舞台上会发生一些事情。演员在舞台上产生一种情感体验，为了娱乐观众。
But those are real emotional experiences. A therapist could help somebody have an emotional experience that's curative in its own right. This isn't for the entertainment of anybody. This is their life. It's for the purposes of health care, that going through certain experiences can be curative, a corrective emotional experience. What kind of poetry did you write at this time of your life? Mostly quite bad poetry. Thanks for asking.
但那些是真实的情感体验。治疗师可以帮助某人获得一种本身具有治愈作用的情感体验。这不是为了娱乐任何人。这是他们的人生。这是为了医疗保健的目的，经历某些体验可以具有治愈作用，带来一种修正性的情感体验。在你生命的那个阶段，你写的是什么类型的诗？基本上都是很烂的诗。谢谢你的提问。
You know, a lot of them, I guess I identified very much with the love-sick kind of unrequited love poetry. right? I think that was also part of an identity that somehow I had, you know, this is like laid out of lessons, early 20s sort of thing. So I understand that you had a girlfriend at the time, someone that you cared about deeply, but at one point the relationship founded? I was very enamored, right? And I think I kind of, you know, the relationship sort of fizzled out. But my approach, I guess, was to lean in harder, right?
你知道，其中很多，我猜我非常认同那种多愁善感、单相思类的诗歌，对吧？我想这也是我当时某种身份认同的一部分，你知道，这是二十多岁左右时那种文艺的调调。所以据我了解，你当时有个女朋友，一个你深爱的人，但后来这段关系破裂了？我当时非常着迷，对吧？而且我想我有点，你知道，这段感情就这样渐渐淡了。但我的方法，我猜，是更加努力地去维系，对吧？
So I had a friend who was also became an actor and a scriptwriter. And that probably didn't help. Probably made things worse looking back. But the last attempt, the rally was to go in this story. underneath her balcony of her apartment to call her out. She comes out on the balcony. And I proceed to serenade her with the help of a of a buddy. And they're singing. A poem might have been read. A big finish bucket of sand with fireworks in it to end it all. Oh my gosh. Yeah, kind of a crash and burn, but very dramatic.
所以我有一个朋友，他也成了一名演员和编剧。这可能没什么帮助。回想起来，可能反而让事情变得更糟了。但最后的尝试，也就是集结号，是去到这个故事。在她公寓的阳台下把她叫出来。她来到阳台上。然后在一位哥们的帮助下，我开始对她进行小夜曲。他们还在唱歌。可能还读了一首诗。最后是大招——一个装有烟花的沙桶，为这一切画上句号。哦天哪。是的，有点惨烈，但非常戏剧化。
You know, and I, looking back, you know, it was about the performance. It wasn't about the relationship, right? And it wasn't about what I needed. There wasn't a lot of relating, actually. I mean, that became a turning point, right? Where I kind of realized, um, I wasn't attending to, to what's happening inside me, which is this, you know, um, uh, sense of insecurity, sense of, what did I really need
你知道，而且我，回想起来，你知道，那全是为了表演。那不是为了这段关系，对吧？也不是为了我真正需要的东西。事实上，并没有多少真正的交流。我的意思是，那成了一个转折点，对吧？我当时意识到，嗯，我没有关注我内心正在发生的事情，也就是这种，嗯，不安全感，这种，我到底真正需要什么
and how do I feel about this and what's missing for me? Did anyone get this serenade and this poetry reading on camera because this would be one for the ages if someone recorded you? I'm very glad that it's not on camera. No, yeah.
以及我对这有什么感受，我缺少了什么？有没有人用摄像头拍下这段小夜曲和诗歌朗诵，因为如果有人录下你当时的场景，那绝对会成为时代的经典？我很庆幸当时没有被拍下来。没有，是的。
In fact, this is the only telling of that story. In fact, I talked to my wingman friend We're now just old friends. And he firmly said to me, definitely do not tell that story. I'm glad you didn't take his advice, Antonio. Now, of course, you know, you're far from the only person. to have had a hard time with a breakup in the 2011 movie Crazy Stupid Love, the actor Steve Carell plays a character who is trying to get over a breakup. Here he is talking to his ex with whom
事实上，这是关于那个故事的唯一一次讲述。事实上，我和我当僚机的那个朋友聊过，我们现在只是老朋友了。他非常坚定地对我说：“绝对不要讲那个故事。”我很高兴你没有听取他的建议，安东尼奥。现在，当然，你知道，你远不是唯一一个在分手时经历艰难时期的人。在2011年的电影《疯狂愚蠢的爱》中，演员史蒂夫·卡瑞尔饰演一个正试图走出分手阴影的角色。这里是他与前妻的对话
he is still in love. Look, when we were first married, you were the only woman that I had ever slept with, and now I have had sex with nine different women. God! Nine? That... Nine? Wow! You showed me. I wasn't trying to show you. I was trying to move on. So, Antonio, you're a therapist. Do you see examples of this kind of behavior in real life?
他依然深爱着前妻。听着，我们刚结婚时，你是唯一一个和我睡过的女人，而现在我已经和九个不同的女人发生过性关系。天哪！九个？那……九个？哇！你可真行。我不是想向你证明什么。我只是想继续生活。所以，安东尼奥，你是一名治疗师。你在现实生活中见过这种行为的例子吗？
Yes, absolutely. I mean, there's sort of a, shall I say, desperate kind of attempt to move on. I mean, it's a behavioral approach. just like, I'm just going to, you know, there's an old saying in Spanish, which is a clavo, saca, other clavo, right? To push out a nail, you just drive in another nail, right? Replacing the old with the new, you know, and that is not something that helps you necessarily figure out what you really need, right? So, I mean, you might get over somebody, but, but, you know, you haven't learned anything from the relationship. You haven't changed. You haven't
是的，绝对见过。我的意思是，有一种，我该怎么说呢，绝望般试图继续生活的方式。我的意思是，这是一种行为方式。就像，我打算，你知道的，西班牙语里有一句老话，叫un clavo, saca otro clavo，对吧？拔出一根钉子，只需钉进另一根钉子，对吧？用新的取代旧的，你知道，这并不一定能帮你弄清楚你真正需要什么，对吧？所以，我的意思是，你可能会忘记某个人，但是，你知道，你并没有从这段关系中学到任何东西。你没有改变。你没有
changed as a person, and you're likely to end up in a similar sort of predicament. So if one model is basically people, you know, trying to plow ahead and not look back, you also have people who do the opposite, who basically are fixated on what happened in the past. In the 2019 movie Marriage Story, we hear the voice of the actor Adam Driver. who plays Charlie, a man in the middle of a very nasty divorce. In this clip, he's addressing his soon-to-be ex-wife. Every day I wake up and I hope you're dead. Dead like, if I can guarantee Henry would be okay.
作为一个人发生改变，你很可能会陷入类似的困境。因此，如果一种模式基本上是人们，你知道的，试图闷头向前冲而不回头，那么也有相反类型的人，他们基本上执着于过去发生的事情。在2019年的电影《婚姻故事》中，我们听到了演员亚当·德赖弗的声音。他饰演查理，一个正处于极其痛苦的离婚过程中的男人。在这个片段中，他正在对即将成为他前妻的人说话。我每天醒来都希望你死掉。死掉的意思是，如果能保证亨利没事的话。
I'd hope you'd get an illness and they can hit by a car and die. Antonio, what do you hear when you hear that very dramatic scene? Well, it's horrible. You know, it's also an example of, I hate you for not loving me. Right? So what's really going on here underneath all the hostile. No, it's anger. It's anger. But the anger is all about it's blaming anger. It's rejecting anger. It's about what I don't want. So what's he fighting for? That's not so clear, right? What are you fighting for? What do you really need? That part's not clear, right? It's clear he wants distance. But that's
我希望你得场病，然后被车撞死。安东尼奥，当你听到那个非常戏剧化的场景时，你听到了什么？嗯，这太可怕了。你知道，这也是一个例子，我恨你，因为你不爱我。对吧？所以，在所有这些充满敌意的背后，真正发生的是什么？不，这是愤怒。这是愤怒。但这种愤怒完全是责备的愤怒。是抗拒的愤怒。是关于我不想要什么的愤怒。那么他在为什么而战？这并不是很清楚，对吧？你在为之战斗什么？你真正需要什么？那部分并不清楚，对吧？很显然他想要保持距离。但那
not an assertion of an existential need, really. So there's, I mean, there are a lot of ways of having poor outcomes. When we look at psychotherapy and you're trying to predict outcome, we generally don't try to predict poor outcomes because there's a million ways of having a poor outcome, lots of reasons why it wouldn't work. And what's interesting is actually there are a few, a finite number of reasons why people have good outcomes. And so that tends to be something, the focus of psychotherapy research. Whether we spend our days brooding for people we love or desperately trying to fill the void of relationships that have slipped away
并不是对生存需求的真正主张。所以，我的意思是，有很多导致糟糕结果的方式。当我们审视心理治疗并试图预测结果时，我们通常不会试图预测糟糕的结果，因为导致糟糕结果的方法有上百万种，有很多原因导致它行不通。而有趣的是，实际上导致良好结果的原因只有少数几个，是有限的。因此，这往往成为心理治疗研究的焦点。无论我们是日复一日地为我们所爱的人黯然神伤，还是绝望地试图填补那些已经逝去的关系所留下的空白，
or exploding in rage at an ex who has wronged us, there are many ways to badly handle the end of a relationship. When we come back, why we have. so bad at breakups and the key to parting well from people we love. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. We can torture ourselves, behave badly toward others, and drive everyone to exasperation. At the University of Windsor and Canada, psychologist Antonio Pasqua Leone studies how and why we go off the rails when it comes to moving on with our lives.
又或是向伤害过我们的前任怒火中烧，有很多方法都无法妥善处理一段关系的结束。当我们回来时，我们将探讨为什么我们如此不擅长分手，以及与我们所爱之人好好告别的关键。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。我们可以折磨自己，对他人行为恶劣，让所有人都感到愤怒。在加拿大的温莎大学，心理学家安东尼奥·帕斯夸莱-莱奥尼研究了当我们在生活中试图继续前行时，我们是如何以及为什么会脱轨的。
So your research has found, Antonio, that people who don't deal with their feelings can get stuck in an undifferentiated state of negative emotion that you call global distress. So as part of the process of unpacking this undifferentiated ball of emotions, you suggest that people get out three pieces of paper and make three lists. What goes on these lists, Antonio? Yeah, I mean, if we were talking about grief, you know, part of the puzzle is what have you lost? And people are often thinking about the good things. What have I lost in terms of what I enjoyed about the relationship and will,
因此，安东尼奥，你的研究发现，那些不处理自己情绪的人可能会陷入一种未分化的负面情绪状态，你称之为“全球性痛苦”。因此，作为解开这个未分化的情绪球的过程的一部分，你建议人们拿出三张纸并列出三个清单。这些清单上都写些什么呢，安东尼奥？是的，我的意思是，如果我们谈论的是悲伤，你知道，谜题的一部分是你失去了什么？人们经常在思考美好的事物。就我所享受的、而且将不复存在的关系而言，我失去了什么，对吧？
no longer come to pass, right? This might be the way we used to have those, the little jokes together or the way, the idiosyncrasies of that person that I cared about. But then you could also think about, you get a different piece of paper if you wanted to do it as an exercise and, you know, saying goodbye to the bad things, the things that I put up with or tolerated. It might be, you know, the idiosyncratic quirks that that person had, which I didn't really enjoy, but was part of the relationship, and you just sort of took it. So that's a different sort of thing, and listing those, right? I never really liked when the person did X, but, and now I don't have to put up with it anymore. So it's almost like a form of accounting in some ways. You're totaling up the
这可能是我们曾经一起开那些小玩笑的方式，或者我所关心的那个人的独特个性。但你也可以思考，如果你想把它作为一个练习的话，拿出一张不同的纸，你知道，对不好的事情说再见，那些我忍受或容忍的事情。它可能是，你知道，那个人身上有一些我并不是真的很享受但又是关系一部分的独特怪癖，而你只是默默接受了。所以那是另一种事情，把它们列出来，对吧？我从来不是很喜欢那个人做X这件事，但是，现在我不用再忍受它了。所以这在某种程度上几乎就像是一种记账方式。你在总计
minuses, but also potentially totaling up the pluses. Yes. And then this third piece is, the hopes and dreams, you know, and this is tricky because there's all sorts of things that you hoped would happen or that you imagined would happen. And those two are part of the relationship. It's like surplus reality, right? It didn't happen, but it was kind of baked into my experience of the relationship. Like one day we would have children or one day we would go on that trip together. And now those things, those will never happen, right? So there's all these undeclared losses and kind of putting up, I'll call it,
负面因素，但也可能在总计正面因素。是的。然后这第三部分是，希望和梦想，你知道，这很棘手，因为有各种各样你希望发生或者你想象会发生的事情。这两者也是关系的一部分。这就像是冗余现实，对吧？它没有发生，但它有点被烘焙进了我对这段关系的体验中。比如有一天我们会生孩子，或者有一天我们会一起去那次旅行。而现在那些事情，那些永远不会发生了，对吧？所以有所有这些未曾宣称的损失，并且建立起，我称之为，
little tombstones for those things, helps make them more real and helps make them easier to let go of. Antonio, you conducted a study that looked at the effects of the various kinds of stories we tell about our experiences. Two kinds of narratives had particularly detrimental effects. The superficial shallow narrative and the type of narrative that you call the same old story. What are these different stories, Antonio? Narratives will both shape the emergence of a story and describe the story. So one thing we were doing is getting people to write about traumatic experiences or the most difficult experiences they've had and then looking at the way they tell those stories, right?
为这些事情竖起的小墓碑，有助于让它们变得更真实，并有助于让人更容易放下它们。安东尼奥，你曾进行过一项研究，探讨了我们讲述的关于自身经历的各种故事的影响。有两种叙事方式具有特别有害的影响。肤浅的浅薄叙事和那种你称之为“老生常谈的故事”的叙事类型。这些不同的故事都是怎样的，安东尼奥？叙事既会塑造故事的产生，也会描述故事。所以我们做的一件事就是让人写下创伤经历或他们经历过的最困难的经历，然后观察他们讲述这些故事的方式，对吧？
And it turned out that there were certain markers, and you've mentioned them here, the sort of the same old story, and also the superficial story. The superficial story is this, you know, might be big. on plot and characters, but never really getting into the deeper experience. And the same old story would be, yes, they get into the emotional experience, but they're stuck in some sort of maladaptive state, right? This is, it's always like this for me. It might be the poor me story, or it might be feeling like a victim, or it might be, I'm just giving some examples, right? when people told stories like that, irrespective of the content, right, it's the manner in which they told their stories, right?
结果发现，确实存在某些标记，你在这里也提到了，那种老生常谈的故事，以及肤浅的故事。肤浅的故事是这样的，你知道，情节和人物可能很大，但从来没有真正进入更深层的体验。而老生常谈的故事则是，是的，他们进入了情感体验，但他们陷入了某种适应不良的状态，对吧？这就是，对我来说总是这样的。它可能是“可怜的我”的故事，或者可能是感觉自己像个受害者，或者可能是，我只是举几个例子，对吧？当人们讲述这样的故事时，不管内容如何，对吧，这是他们讲述故事的方式，对吧？
So this is the phrasing, this is highlighting certain things, irrespective of the content. We could actually predict symptoms, their symptom level. So depressive symptoms, anxious symptoms, even trauma symptoms. So I can't stress enough. It isn't that they're telling stories about trauma and therefore they've suffered trauma. It's rather the way they tell this story, you know, and so it's like I can tell I know what you're feeling, meaning I know what your symptoms are to some degree and the symptom severity based on how people are telling their stories.
所以这是措辞，这是对某些事情的强调，与内容无关。我们实际上可以预测症状，他们的症状水平。因此，抑郁症状、焦虑症状，甚至是创伤症状。所以我怎么强调都不为过。并不是因为他们在讲述关于创伤的故事，因此他们遭受了创伤。而是他们讲述这个故事的方式，你知道，所以这就像是我能看出你的感觉，意思是根据人们讲述故事的方式，我在某种程度上知道你的症状是什么以及症状的严重程度。
So in other words, you're looking as a therapist to not just what the stories are, but sort of the form of the stories, the form the stories are taking. Yeah, because you can think of emotion. in terms of immediate experience, but it also gets embellished and elaborated as a narrative, right? And sometimes people cling to a certain emotional loop or an emotional state becomes the centerpiece of the story they tell about who I am. So you've mentioned that you are married now, Antonio, but before you met your wife, you were in another romantic relationship that came to an end. You were able to use that
换句话说，作为一名治疗师，你关注的不仅是故事本身，还有故事的形式，也就是故事所采用的形式。是的，因为你可以从即时体验的角度来思考情感，但它也会作为一种叙事被点缀和详细阐述，对吧？有时人们会执着于某个情感循环，或者某种情感状态成为他们讲述“我是谁”这个故事的核心。你提到过你现在已经结婚了，安东尼奥，但在遇到妻子之前，你还有过一段最终结束的浪漫关系。你能够利用那个
ending as a kind of forge for making yourself into a different and better person. Tell me the story of what happened and what you did. Well, yeah, I mean, I remember being in a relationship and leaning into it. And, yeah, I guess now that I'm thinking about this, sort of a theme here, right? I mean, not wanting to be the reason why the relationship ends, right? And in some sense, she was the brave one. And she ended the relationship, which had come to a kind of a natural conclusion.
结局作为一种锻炉，把自己塑造一个不同且更好的人。告诉我发生了什么以及你做了什么的故事。好吧，是的，我的意思是，我记得曾身处一段关系中并努力去投入其中。而且，是的，我想现在我在思考这个时，这里有一个主题，对吧？我的意思是，不想成为导致关系结束的原因，对吧？从某种意义上说，她是勇敢的那一个。她结束了这段已经走到自然终点的关系。
Relationships really need to be reinvented every seven years or so. but this one had run its course and and yet I was having trouble letting go of it and just wanted to make it work right but then when it became really clear the relationship was ending and was over I guess I realize that you know the way you handle the end of a relationship defines you in some way or that it would define me, right? I mean, I'm the kind of person who, and then you fill in the blank for yourself, right? If you're the kind of person who's hateful and angry and destructive, well, then that's who you are, right? And I think there's kind of a moment where I realize that this is an opportunity to honor the relationship to, you know,
关系确实需要每隔七年左右重新发明一次，但这关系已经走到了尽头，然而我却很难放手，只想让它运转起来，对吧？但后来，当关系明确结束并且已经完结时，我猜我意识到，你知道你处理关系结束的方式在某种程度上定义了你，或者说它会定义我，对吧？我的意思是，我是那种人，然后你自己对号入座，对吧？如果你是那种充满怨恨、愤怒和破坏性的人，好吧，那这就是你，对吧？并且我认为有一个时刻我意识到这是一个向关系致敬的机会，去，你知道的，
know, I was unhappy that it was ending, but at the same time it was somebody I learned a lot from. This was somebody who I cared for, who cared for me. The relationship's now over. And in some sense, give it the funeral it deserved, right? I think that changed me because it's a choice point, an existential choice point. I think I also came out with a with a sense of clarity or a sense of direction, realizing that I needed somebody that was ready to put me first, that was ready to champion me in a way. You know, there's an old definition of love is something along the lines of when you are able to make other people's needs your own, right?
我为它的结束感到不快，但与此同时这也是一个让我学到很多东西的人。这是一个我关心过、也关心过我的人。关系现在已经结束了。从某种意义上说，给它应有的葬礼，对吧？我认为这改变了我，因为它是一个抉择点，一个生存抉择点。我想我也带着一种清晰感或方向感走出来，意识到我需要一个准备好把我放在第一位的人，一个准备好以某种方式支持我的人。你知道，对爱有一个古老的定义，大致是当你能够把别人的需求变成你自己的需求时，对吧？
or kind of support somebody in what they need. And so I was willing to do that for somebody, but I also needed somebody who was willing to do that for me. When I met my future wife, I knew it was right. And I think that was part of the ending of the relationship in a clarifying way, where you realize you're both the off. and the reader of your own story. There are times when relationships don't just come undone.
或者在别人需要的时候支持某人。所以我愿意为某人这样做，但我也需要一个愿意为我这样做的人。当我遇到未来的妻子时，我知道这是对的。我想那是关系结束的一部分，以一种澄清的方式，让你意识到你既是自己故事的作者，也是读者。有时候，关系不仅仅是分崩离析。
They explode. They blow up. Couples don't just drift apart. They betray each other and then disappear from each other's lives. Parents don't just pass away. They leave behind complicated histories and long-buried secrets. Their children are left with endless questions. As we grapple with the end of such relationships, we may feel we cannot get closure until we know the answers to our questions.
它们会爆炸。它们会彻底破裂。情侣们不仅仅是渐行渐远。他们背叛彼此，然后从彼此的生活中消失。父母不仅仅是离世。他们留下了复杂的历史和深埋的秘密。他们的孩子则留下了无尽的疑问。当我们努力应对这种关系的结束时，我们可能会觉得，在知道我们问题的答案之前，我们无法获得释怀。
But those answers are not forthcoming. In some cases, the person is no longer alive. In others, the person has disappeared or is otherwise inaccessible. When we come back, how can we deal with situations like this where we feel we have been left in limbo. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Do you have questions for Antonio Pascual Leone
但这些答案并没有出现。在某些情况下，这个人已经不在人世了。在另一些情况下，这个人已经消失了，或者无法接触。当我们回来时，我们将探讨如何处理这样一种让我们感到悬而未决的局面。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。你对安东尼奥·帕斯夸莱-莱奥尼有什么问题吗？
about breakups that you've experienced in your own life? Are there losses that have left you feeling stuck? Have you come up with techniques of your own to move past to break up and discover a better version of yourself. If you'd be willing to share your question or comment with the Hidden Brain audience, please record a voice memo on your phone and email it to us at Ideas at Hiddenbrain.org. Two or three minutes is plenty. Use the subject line, breakups.
关于你在自己生活中经历过的分手？有没有什么损失让你感到自己卡壳了？你有没有想出过自己的技巧来度过分手期并发现一个更好的自己？如果你愿意与《隐藏的大脑》的听众分享你的问题或评论，请在手机上录制语音备忘录并通过电子邮件发送给我们，邮箱是Ideas at Hiddenbrain.org。两到三分钟就足够了。使用主题行：分手。
Again, that's Ideas at Hiddenbrain.org. There are many situations. in life where the end of a relationship brings endless questions. Sometimes those are questions we can answer for ourselves, but other times we need answers from a lost partner or an absent co-worker or a dead parent, answers that are not forthcoming. Without being able to understand how and why the relationship came apart, we feel we cannot move forward with our own lives. Antonio Pascoa Leone is a psychologist at the University of Windsor and Canada. He is the author of Principles of Emotion Change, What Works and When, in Psychotherapy and Everyday Life.
再次说明，邮箱是Ideas at Hiddenbrain.org。生活中有很多情况，关系的结束会带来无穷无尽的问题。有时这些是我们自己能回答的问题，但有时我们需要失去的伴侣、不在场的同事或死去的父母给我们答案，而这些答案并未出现。如果没有能力理解这段关系是如何以及为什么破裂的，我们会觉得自己的生活无法继续前进。安东尼奥·帕斯夸莱-莱奥尼是加拿大温莎大学的心理学家。他是《情绪改变原则：心理治疗和日常生活中的有效方法与时机》一书的作者。
Antonio, you say that one reason grief is sometimes complicated is because our current situation stirs up older and sometimes deeper hurts. I understand that you once got to know a woman who discovered that she was being cheated on, And instead of getting mad at her former partner, she got mad at herself. Tell me that story and how in some ways it points to this idea that sometimes when we have setbacks in our lives, it makes us question ourselves rather than question the setback. Right. So she was saying things like, I feel like an idiot. I feel I must have been, I'm, you know, I'm such a fool is something that really stuck with me. Her saying, I'm such a fool. How could I, you know, have been so blue. that this was happening and so on and so forth.
安东尼奥，你说悲伤有时会变得复杂的一个原因是，我们当前的处境会激发出更旧、有时也更深的伤痛。我听说你曾经认识一位女性，她发现自己被出轨了，但她没有生前伴侣的气，反而生自己的气。请告诉我这个故事，以及它在某种程度上如何说明这个观点：有时当我们在生活中遭遇挫折时，它会让我们质疑自己，而不是质疑挫折本身。没错。所以她当时说的话比如，我觉得自己像个白痴。我觉得我当时一定是，你知道，我真是个傻瓜，这句话深深印在我的脑海里。她说：“我真是个傻瓜。我怎么能，你知道，糊涂到这种地步
And of course, it rattles her, right? It's not just the loss. It's of a relationship because the relationship was ending. But it's also, you know, rocked her confidence. Yeah. And these sort of doubts about feeling adequate, feeling lovable, feeling attractive enough, feeling, you know, like somebody wants to spend their life with me. You know, so that's an injury to identity in some ways.
竟然发生这种事等等。”当然，这让她心神不定，对吧？这不仅仅是关系的丧失，因为关系正在结束。这也是对她自信心的打击。是的。以及诸如自己是否足够好、是否值得被爱、是否足够有吸引力、是否，你知道的，像有人想和我共度一生这样的怀疑。你知道，这在某种程度上是对身份认同的伤害。
There was one time when you had your own heartbroken Antonio and the woman who was saying goodbye to you left you with a parting shot that really stuck with you in a distressing way. What happened? So yeah, I mean, that's in some ways a similar example, right? I mean, I was quite young and, you know, a teenager, what? And it was somebody saying to me, you know, we were sort of breaking up and I wanted to know why. You know, the why question is never a real question. When people want to know why, it's not a real question. It's a rhetorical question, right?
曾经有一次你自己的心也碎了，安东尼奥，那个向你道别的女人留下了一句刻薄的分手寄语，以一种令人痛苦的方式深深印在你的脑海里。发生了什么？所以，是的，我的意思是，这在某种程度上是一个类似的例子，对吧？我的意思是，我当时很年轻，你知道，一个十几岁的人，什么？那是有人对我说，你知道，我们当时正在分手，而我想知道为什么。为什么这个问题从来都不是一个真正的问题。当人们想知道为什么时，这不是一个真正的问题。这是一个修辞问题，对吧？
It's, I don't want to break up. But in any case, I was really hooked on why. And she said to me, well, you're just not good at getting stuff done, which was, yikes, it was right, right in my soft spot, right? Because I had my own doubts. I had my own things. I was struggling. I was young. I wasn't, you know, wasn't always very assertive and was having trouble, you know, blossoming into the kind of person I wanted to be. So, I mean, I mean, that was particularly difficult. It's kind of like a mercy killing, really, because it also helped end the relationship. But ending the relationship, I think this is to your point, ending the relationship left me with a wound that no longer was related to the loss of the person, but was an injury to my sense of self. Another reason our grief might be complicated is that we learn something about the person we've lost that is hard for us to accept. I want to play you a clip from the 2011 movie The Descendants.
意思是，我不想分手。但无论如何，我真的很纠结于“为什么”。她对我说：“嗯，你就是不擅长把事情做好。”这可真是，哎呀，正中我的软肋，对吧？因为我也有自己的疑虑。我有我自己的事情。我在苦苦挣扎。我很年轻，你知道，并不总是那么自信，而且在绽放成我想成为的那种人的过程中遇到了麻烦。所以，我的意思是，这特别困难。这有点像安乐死，真的，因为它也帮助结束了这段关系。但结束这段关系，我想这就是你的观点，结束这段关系给我留下的伤口不再与失去这个人有关，而是对我自我认同感的一种伤害。悲伤可能复杂的另一个原因是，我们了解到了关于那个我们失去的人的一些让我们难以接受的事情。我想播放一段2011年电影《后人》中的片段。
It features a man named Matt, played by George Clooney. His wife suffers a serious injury and goes into a coma. Matt then discovers that she has been having an affair. In this clip, Matt talks to his wife. as she lies unconscious in a hospital bed, she cannot hear him and she cannot respond. You're going to ask me for a divorce so you could be with some Brian Spear. Are you kidding me? Who are you? The only thing I know for sure is you're a goddamn liar. So what do you have to say for yourself? I should go ahead and make a little joke and tell me that I got it all wrong.
片中由乔治·克鲁尼饰演一个名叫马特的男人。他的妻子受了重伤并陷入昏迷。马特随后发现妻子一直在与人有染。在这段片段中，马特对躺在医院病床上的妻子说话。她听不到他说的话，也无法回应。你要跟我离婚，好去跟那个布라이언·斯皮尔在一起。你在开玩笑吗？你到底是谁？我唯一能确定的事就是你是个该死的骗子。所以你有什么好为自己辩解的？我应该直接开个小玩笑，然后告诉我我全都搞错了。
Tell me again that I'm too out of touch with my feelings, and I need to go to therapy. Isn't the idea of marriage to make your partner's way in life a little easier? For me, it was always harder with you, and you're still making it harder. Lying there on a ventilator and my life. You are relentless. So you can hear Antonio how complicated this is for George Clooney's character. He's dealing with a partner who has suffered life. threatening injuries, but she's also hurt him.
再次告诉我，我对自己的感情太不敏感了，我需要去看心理治疗。难道婚姻的理念不应该是让伴侣在人生道路上稍微好走一点吗？对我而言，跟你在一起总是更难，而且你还在让它变得更难。躺在呼吸机上，我的生活。你真是毫不留情。所以你可以听到，安东尼奥，乔治·克鲁尼饰演的角色有多么纠结。他正在和一个遭受了生命威胁性伤害的伴侣打交道，但她也伤害了他。
He doesn't have a way of getting answers out of her. Yeah. I mean, so there's a couple of things going on, right? This is an issue of betrayal. You know, and he's angry, and you can hear that, but he's also really hurt. The fact that she can't answer, you know, people are often feeling like they need to have a conversation or finish somehow. to get closure. But there are ways to do that that don't really involve the other person, right?
他没有办法从她那里得到答案。是的。我的意思是，所以有几件事正在发生，对吧？这是一个背叛的问题。你知道，他很生气，你能听出来，但他也真的很受伤。她无法回答这一事实，你知道，人们经常觉得他们需要进行一次对话或者以某种方式结束
Can you say more about that? Because I think when most of us think about getting closure, especially in a situation like this, we think it's very much about the other person. We want the other person to explain themselves, to apologize, to beg our forgiveness because they've heard us. How is this not about the other person, Antonio? Well, I mean, of course,
来获得释怀。但有些方法并不真正需要另一个人参与，对吧？
it's about the other person in the sense that I've had an interaction with the other person, but it means something to me. And the unfinished business I have is my own. You can't change the historical facts, but you can change quite a lot what you feel about it. When you think about it, you can change what it means.
你能多说一点吗？因为我认为当我们大多数人想到获得释怀时，尤其是在这种情况下，我们认为这很大程度上与另一个人有关。我们希望另一个人向我们解释，向我们道歉，恳求我们的原谅，因为他们伤害了我们。安东尼奥，为什么这不关于另一个人呢？嗯，我的意思是，当然，
And, you know, even some of the details of what you remember, memory is actually very dynamic, and more dynamic than what people tend to believe. In the end, exactly what happened or what was said matters less than what it means and what I'm going to do with it, right? In working with victims of trauma or complex trauma, sometimes the other person isn't, like in this clip, you know, a partner or an ex-partner who's unconscious in a hospital bed, but it was actually a perpetrator, right, of abuse. Um, that kind of person is not a person, usually that one can have a conversation with. They're not going to acknowledge the abuse. So clients will say things like I, I've told them and they deny it.
这在我和另一个人有过互动的意义上是关于另一个人的，但它对我意味着什么。我未了的心愿是我自己的。你无法改变历史事实，但你可以大大改变你对它的感受。当你仔细想想时，你可以改变它的含义。而且，你知道，甚至连你记忆的一些细节也是如此，记忆实际上是非常动态的，比人们倾向于认为的要动态得多。到头来，到底发生了什么或者说了什么并不重要，重要的是它意味着什么，以及我将用它做什么。在与创伤或复杂创伤的受害者合作时，有时另一个人不是，就像在这个片段中那样，一个昏迷在医院病床上的伴侣或前任，而实际上是一个虐待者，对吧？那种人通常不是可以与之对话的人。他们不会承认虐待。所以客户会说这样的话：“我，我告诉过他们，但他们否认了。”
And it's sort of like, yeah, yeah, they, I agree. That's not a conversation you can actually have with them because they always deny it or dismiss it or or shut you down. So actually not having the person here. can be more useful. In some ways, Antonio, what you're saying is that the relationship might have been a shared project, but getting closure for the relationship does not need to be a shared project. That's exactly right. Me getting over the relationship is no longer a shared project. Me deciding what it means to me.
这就好像是，对，对，他们，我同意。那不是你能真正与他们进行的对话，因为他们总是会否认、驳回或打发你。所以实际上没有这个人在场会更有用。在某种程度上，安东尼奥，你的意思是，这段关系可能是一个共同的项目，但为这段关系获得释怀并不需要是一个共同的项目。完全正确。我走出这段关系不再是一个共同的项目。我决定它对我的意义。
It doesn't have to mean the same thing to me as it does to the other person. We often have, you know, there's this question of, Well, isn't it just better to talk to the other person? And there was a study that kind of looked at. That's a great question, right? An imagined dialogue versus a real dialogue. So this was basically a study where what they were treating was suicidal adolescents who had essentially unfinished business with parents, right?
它对我来说不必和对另一个人意味着同样的事情。我们经常有，你知道的，有这样一个问题，“嗯，直接和另一个人谈谈不是更好吗？”曾有一项研究探讨了这一点。这是一个很好的问题，对吧？想象中的对话与真实的对话。所以这基本上是一项研究，他们治疗的是基本上与父母有未了心愿的自杀倾向青少年，对吧？
There were rifts that were very painful related to the adolescence, suicide. And, you know, they could randomize and treat in two ways. One, you could put them in family therapy where they actually have dialogues with the parent about what's going on. Or you can put them in individual therapy and have imagined dialogues where they imagine their, but the parent is alive is living somewhere else. But they're imagining a dialogue here. You know, and so this is really interesting. It answers that question because you actually get different outcomes, different kinds of outcomes. So if what you're looking for is relationship resolution, if what you're looking for is to improve the relationship, have a better relationship, then having a real dialogue with a
存在与自杀相关的非常痛苦的裂痕。而且，你知道，他们可以随机分组并以两种方式进行治疗。第一种，你可以把他们安排在家庭治疗中，让他们真正与父母就正在发生的事情进行对话。或者你可以把他们安排在个体治疗中，进行想象中的对话，让他们想象他们的，但父母还活着，住在其他地方。但他们在这里想象对话。你知道，这真的很有趣。它回答了那个问题，因为你实际上会得到不同的结果，不同种类的结果。因此，如果你寻找的是关系解决，如果你寻找的是改善关系、建立更好的关系，那么与一个
real person is going to be more effective, right? That's where you'll see the change and the quality of their relationship. Not necessarily in the degree to which they've worked through their own. unfinished business, right? So you can repair the relationship and still not feel entirely resolved. On the other hand, if you had people imagine a dialogue, emotional processing, I'll call it, is better if the dialogue is imaginary. So they're working through is their own project. Even if the person is alive, right? You still need to do your work. They can't process it for you. So you say that one thing that people can do is that you can write an email to the other person but never send it
真实的人进行真正的对话会更有效，对吧？那是你会看到关系改变和质量提升的地方。不一定是在他们处理自身未了心愿的程度上，对吧？所以你可以修复关系，但仍然感觉没有完全解决。另一方面，如果你让人们想象对话，情感加工，我这样称呼它，如果对话是虚构的，效果会更好。所以他们在进行的是他们自己的项目。即使这个人还活着，对吧？你仍然需要做你的工作。他们无法为你处理这些。所以你说人们可以做的一件事就是你可以给另一个人写一封电子邮件但从不发送
or write a letter to the other person but never send it. What would be the value of doing this, Antonio? Yeah, you know, so the idea is there might be things to say And you need to clarify the boundary violation, if that's what it is. Or you need to clarify what you're defending or what the loss is for you to move on, to unhitch and to move on with that. Teaching the other person a lesson or educating them or correcting them. You know, that's often what people are wanting to do, right?
或者给另一个人写一封信但从不发送。这样做有什么价值呢？是的，你知道，所以这个想法是可能有些话要说，你需要澄清边界违规，如果那是的话。或者你需要澄清你正在捍卫的是什么，或者为了继续前进、解开羁绊并继续生活，对你的损失是什么。给另一个人上一课、教育他们或纠正他们。你知道，这通常是人们想要做的，对吧？
Or punish them. I mean, that's not really going to get. you, the change you're looking for. And you'd have to actually ask yourself, do I really want to re-educate the person? Is that really what this is about? So the idea is to have a venue where you can express yourself with clarity. You could sit and think about it. Turns out that thinking about your difficulties is not particularly effective. There's something about writing it down in some form, whether it be an email. That's tricky because you really want to hit the send button.
或者惩罚他们。我的意思是，这并不能真正带给你你所寻找的改变。你不得不问自己：“我真的想重新教育这个人吗？这真的是关于这个的吗？”所以这个想法是拥有一个可以让你清晰表达自己的场地。你可以坐下来思考。事实证明，思考你的困难并不是特别有效。把它们以某种形式写下来，无论是通过电子邮件，这很棘手，因为你真的很想点击发送按钮。
But, you know, writing a letter, these are ways that compel you, that put you in a scenario. Therapy is similar, right? Puts you in a scenario where you have to create sort of a coherent story of what you're feeling and why. You know, so the scenario puts demands on you to be more clear and more coherent than if you were just going for a walk and, daydreaming about it. People's daydreams about their emotional difficulties tend to be
但是，你知道，写一封信，这些都是迫使你的方式，把你置于一个场景中。治疗也是类似的，对吧？把你置于一个场景中，你必须创造一个关于你的感受和原因的连贯故事。你知道，所以这个场景对你提出了要求，要比你只是去散步和胡思乱想时更加清晰和连贯。人们对情绪困扰的白话幻想往往是
full of incomplete sentences or the analog of that, right, and lack clarity. So it's good to have a formal exercise of some sort. Might just be talking to another person. You've sometimes, as you're working with clients, you'll have them pull out an empty chair and have a conversation with the empty chair. What's the value of doing this, Antonio? It's very evocative. I think this is the first thing, right? So if you need to activate emotion and you do,
充满不完整的句子或与之类似的表达，缺乏清晰度。所以进行某种形式的正式练习是好的。可能只是和另一个人交谈。有时你在与客户合作时，会让他们搬出一张空椅子，与空椅子对话。这样做有什么价值，安东尼奥？这非常具有唤起力。我认为这是第一点，对吧？所以如果你需要激活情绪，而你确实需要，
people need to feel their feelings, right? And one way of activating emotion is to imagine the other person. People do this all the time. I mean, you talk to yourself in the mirror. You kind of imagine, at least I do it all the time. My wife is always like, who are you talking to now?
人们需要感受他们的情绪，对吧？而激活情绪的一种方法是想象另一个人。人们一直在这样做。我的意思是，你对着镜子自言自语。你多少会想象，至少我一直这样做。我妻子总是问：“你现在在和谁说话？”
I'm like, I'm not. I'm brushing my teeth. But, you know, like, you know, there's, there's a clarity you have in imagining a conversation, but it's also much more evocative. Imagine the difference between telling somebody, now we're not talking about unfinished business, we're talking expressing love here. But if you say, oh, I really love so and so, or you imagine they say, I love you and use their name, I mean, the second is much more evocative, right? Or I forgive you or I'll never forgive you. I mean, saying it to somebody in an imagined scenario is much more evocative. So it evokes emotion. That's the first thing. It helps with clarity. So you clarify what you're feeling. You can say the things that you would never be able to say in
我说：“没有。我在刷牙。”但是，你知道，就像，你知道，在想象对话时你有一种清晰感，但它也更具唤起力。想象一下告诉某人的区别，现在我们不是在谈论未了的心愿，我们在这里表达爱。但如果你说：“哦，我真的很爱某某，”或者你想象他们说：“我爱你”并使用他们的名字，我的意思是，第二种更具唤起力，对吧？或者“我原谅你”或者“我永远不会原谅你”。我的意思是，在想象的场景中对某人说这些要唤起力得多。所以它会唤起情绪。这是第一件事。它有助于清晰度。所以你澄清了你的感受。你可以说那些你在现实生活中永远无法说出口的话。
real life. Right. So sometimes there's a vulnerability or what or a conversation. You can have conversations with people who are no longer available, who are passed away. But then you can also taking it a step further, you could actually change chairs. And, you know, it's that come over here and be the other person. What happens? You know, what would they say if they could hear you? And this is an entirely fabricated part of reality. It's definitely not a rehearsal.
没错。所以有时存在脆弱性或者谈话。你可以与那些不再可用、已经去世的人进行对话。但随后你还可以更进一步，你实际上可以换椅子，并且，你知道，就是“过来这里，做另一个人”。会发生什么？你知道，如果他们能听到你的声音，他们会说什么？这是现实中完全虚构的一部分。这绝对不是排练。
But there's an unpacking, a meaning, there's always expectations and things that that one has of other people. I could give examples of where people in therapy sort of reveal an understanding of the other person or rather they create an understanding of the other person that they didn't have by enacting them. You tell the story of one of your clients who, you tell the story of one of your clients who had a very difficult relationship with his father. And in a session, you had the man talk to an empty chair, but also then exchange places and sit in the empty chair and talk to the other chair.
但这里有一个剖析、一个意义，总会有期望以及一个人对其他人的种种看法。我可以举一些例子，在心理学治疗中，人们通过将对方演绎出来，从而展现出对另一个人的某种理解，或者说，他们创造了一种原本并不具备的对另一个人的理解。你讲述了你的一个客户的故事，你讲述了你的一个客户的故事，他与父亲的关系非常困难。在一次治疗中，你让这个人对着一把空椅子说话，然后又互换位置，坐在空椅子上对另一把椅子说话。
Tell me what happened, Antonio. So, yeah, that's the sort of changing that I'm talking about. This was a client who had suffered a lot of trauma. But what was salient to this person was the constant criticism, the teaching of a lesson with a very hard hand. And at some point, you know, in working through, he was saying, you know, what my father doesn't understand is. And I had him speak to speak him. Tell him what he doesn't understand. And here there's an unpacking of a conversation that isn't permissible. That could never happen. That wouldn't be
告诉我发生了什么，安东尼奥。所以，是的，这就是我所说的那种改变。这是一个经历过很多创伤的客户。但对这个人来说，最突出的是不断的批评，用非常严厉的手段给人上课。在某个时刻，你知道，在深入探讨的过程中，他说，你知道，我父亲不明白的是。我让他开口说话。把他不明白的事告诉他。在这里，人们剖析了一场原本不被允许的对话。这是绝不可能发生的。这是绝不会被……
tolerated, for example, by the father. And then as you're saying, a next step. Come over here. what would it be like for your father? Like in his heart of hearts. If he could hear this, if it could somehow make sense to him, how might he respond? And this is fabricated, right? This is an invention,
例如，被父亲容忍的。然后，正如你所说，下一步。到这儿来。你的父亲会有什么感受？比如在他的内心深处。如果他能听到这些，如果这在某种程度上对他来说说得通，他会作何反应？这是虚构的，对吧？这是捏造的，
but it's full of the client's deeper understandings, projections and expectations of his own father. And he imagines, you know, he can imagine his father expressing a regret and says, you know, I'm like, I'm sorry. I'm anxious. I'm just fearful. Really, I regret being so mean. I'm a nasty, miserable person, but it's like I'm, I'm anxious for you, right? I mean, that doesn't make the abuse any less abusive. It doesn't excuse it. But for the client, it starts to mean something different. You know, and later the client says to me,
但这其中充满了客户对自己的父亲更深层的理解、投射和期望。他想象，你知道，他可以想象他的父亲表达遗憾并说，你知道，我像，我很抱歉。我很焦虑。我只是感到害怕。说实话，我后悔自己那么刻薄。我是个讨厌的、痛苦的人，但这就像我，我为你感到焦虑，对吧？我的意思是，这并没有让虐待变得不那么虐待。这并不能为之辩解。但对客户来说，这开始意味着不同的东西。你知道，后来客户对我说，
I don't think he says, I don't think my dad could ever explain that about himself. He doesn't really, he doesn't know why he's mean, but I know. And the client ends up in some ways forgiving his father for their terrible relationship, which isn't always the way these things work out. And there's not a mandate for that. But it was a very interesting turn. He decides to forgive his father, but to always keep a healthy distance.
我不认为他说，我不认为我爸爸能对自己做出那样的解释。他真的不知道，他不知道自己为什么刻薄，但我知道。这个客户在某种程度上最终原谅了父亲，原谅了他们糟糕的关系，事情并不总是这样发展的。而且也没有这方面的强制要求。但这一个非常有趣的转折。他决定原谅他的父亲，但始终保持着健康的距离。
He says, I'm going to shield my daughter from her grandfather. He's a mean guy. You had an Aunt Antonio to whom you were very close. Tell me her story and how your relationship with her evolved over time. Yeah. I don't have a lot of extended family. I never met my grandparents on either side because my parents immigrated and they were older. But I had an aunt who was the oldest person in the family.
他说，我要保护我的女儿，不让她接近她的爷爷。他是个刻薄的人。你有一个叫安东尼奥的姑姑，你跟她非常亲近。跟我讲讲她的故事，以及你和她的关系是如何随着时间发展的。是的。我没有很多大家庭。我从来没见过我父母任何一方的祖父母，因为我父母是移民，而且他们年纪比较大。但我有一个姑姑，她是家里年纪最大的人。
And I was very close to, I mean, when I was born, she actually named me, right? She named me after her husband, my first name. And they were like grandparents to me in many ways. They were an aunt and uncle. They never had children of their own. They couldn't. And so I guess there was a closeness. I mean, they had other nephews and nieces.
而且我跟她很亲近，我是说，我出生时，实际上是她给我取的名字，对吧？我的名字是根据她的丈夫取的，作为我的名字。在很多方面，他们就像我的祖父母一样。他们是姑姑和叔叔。他们自己从来没有过孩子。他们不能生。所以我想这就是那种亲密感吧。我的意思是，他们还有其他的侄子侄女。
But for me, it was a very special relationship. It was for them too. And she was brilliant. She was like a prize-winning researcher in endocrinology and very vivacious and sharp-witted, right? And so in some ways, a role. model. And I remember her, you know, I've been writing this, this giant book, which is now finished. But I, you know, I, I mentioned her in the dedication. I was looking forward to showing it to her. But it, but she died. The thing is, you know, she dies at 91, just, just this past
但对我和他们来说，这都是一段非常特殊的感情。她非常聪明。她就像是内分泌学领域一位得过奖的研究人员，非常活泼，思维敏捷，对吧？所以在某种程度上，她是一个榜样。我记得她，你知道，我一直在写这本厚厚的大书，现在已经完成了。但我，你知道，我在致谢中提到了她。我本来很期待把它拿给她看。但是，它，但她去世了。问题是，你知道，她以91岁的高龄去世了，就在，就在去年。
year. So there's the loss of the person. But she also started to. lose herself a little bit. She suffered dementia in her last, it became more obvious in the last year or two. And so she became quite different, right? So, you know, I remember visiting her in Spain and sitting across from her and talking and she wasn't there anymore. So it's quite hard to say goodbye to someone or to a relationship when they're sitting right there. So that's kind of, you know, the analog is the person's there. They're not really available. I don't really want to say goodbye, but the relationship has ended, right?
所以不仅是失去了这个人。而且她也开始……稍微失去了自我。她在生命的最后几年患上了痴呆症，在过去的一两年里，这种症状变得更加明显。所以她变得很不一样了，对吧？所以，你知道，我记得我去西班牙看望她，坐在她对面和她说话，而她已经不在那里了。因此，当一个人就坐在那里时，向他们或向一段关系告别是相当困难的。所以这有点像，你知道，类比就是那个人还在。他们实际上并不在状态。我其实不想说再见，但这段关系已经结束了，对吧？
Part of the process, you know, and I, you know, I cleaned out her apartment, big apartment. I think that was part of, you know, part of it to sort of, you know, and you go through people's stuff. And she doesn't know, but I know. I guess I'm not finished yet, right? But I still need to find a way to kind of honor that relationship. I'll go to Spain, actually, on sabbatical. My kids are eight and ten. So they're actually about the age where I remember feeling really close to her.
部分过程是，你知道，我，你知道，我清理了她的公寓，很大的公寓。我想这也是其中的一部分，你知道，去，你知道，你会翻看别人的东西。她不知道，但我知道。我想我还没结束，对吧？但我仍然需要找到一种方式来纪念那段感情。实际上我将去西班牙进行学术休假。我的孩子分别是八岁和十岁。所以他们现在的年龄，正是我记忆中感觉自己与她非常亲近的年龄。
So I guess I will show my kids around and maybe bring a bit of that back in a different form. I'm wondering if I can ask you to do one thing that you ask your clients to do. I'm wondering if you can sit in the empty chair and tell me how your aunt would have responded to your dedication of the book to her, but also how you felt about her. Oh, you got any comments? Kleenex, you know, I would think she would say, she would say, Antonio,
所以我想我会带我的孩子们四处看看，也许能以不同的形式把那种感觉带回来。我想知道我能否请你做一件事，一件你要求你的客户去做的事。我想知道你是否可以坐在空椅子上，告诉我你的姑姑会如何回应你把这本书献给她，以及你是如何看待她的。噢，你有什么评论吗？纸巾，你知道的，我想她会说，她会说，安东尼奥，
I'm really proud of you. It's a good, I'm proud of you. I'm proud of how you honored the people in our family. and when I say that, if I imagine her saying that, it gives me a sense of, I feel good. I was going to say proud, but it's more like I just feel good. I'm really happy that I'll be bringing my kids to Spain, visiting some of the places she showed me
我真的为你感到骄傲。这是一本好书，我为你骄傲。我为你如何尊重我们家族里的人感到骄傲。当我这么说时，如果我幻想着她这么说，它会给我一种感觉，我感觉很好。我本想说自豪，但更像是自我感觉良好。我真的很高兴能带我的孩子们去西班牙，去参观一些她带我去过的地方，
and that creates kind of a continuity. I'm excited. I'm looking forward to the future. Antonio Pascual Leone is a psychologist at the University of Windsor in Canada. He's the author of Principles of Emotion Change, What Works and When in Psychotherapy and Everyday Life. Antonio, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you, Shankar. It was a delight to talk about this work and a really refreshing interview.
这创造了一种连续性。我很兴奋。我非常期待未来。安东尼奥·帕斯夸尔·莱昂是加拿大温莎大学的心理学家。他是《情绪改变的原理：心理治疗和日常生活中的有效方法与时机》一书的作者。安东尼奥，非常感谢你今天做客“隐秘大脑”。谢谢你，尚卡尔。很高兴能谈论这项工作，这是一次非常令人耳目一新的采访。
Do you have questions for Antonio Pasquale-Leone about breakups that you've experienced in your own life? Are there losses that have left you feeling stuck? Have you come up with techniques of your own to move past breakups and discover a better version of yourself? If you'd be willing to share your question or story or comment with the hidden brain audience, please record a voice memo on your phone and email it to us, at Ideas at Hiddenbrain.org. Two or three minutes is plenty. Use the subject line, breakups.
关于你在生活中经历过的情感破裂，你对安东尼奥·帕斯夸尔-莱昂有什么问题吗？有没有哪些失去让你感到难以释怀？你有没有想出自己的独家技巧来走出情感破裂并发现更好的自己？如果你愿意与“隐秘大脑”的听众分享你的问题、故事或评论，请在手机上录制一段语音备忘录并将其发送至我们的邮箱：Ideas at Hiddenbrain.org。两到三分钟就足够了。请使用主题行：情感破裂。
Again, that's Ideas at Hiddenbrain.org. After the break, our popular segment, your questions answered. Cognitive scientist Phil Fernback returns to the show to respond to your thoughts and questions about what's known as the illusion of knowledge. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedant. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta.
再次重申，邮箱是 Ideas at Hiddenbrain.org。休息过后，是我们的热门栏目“解答你的疑问”。认知科学家菲尔·费恩巴赫重返节目，回应你们关于所谓“知识错觉”的想法和疑问。你正在收听的是“隐秘大脑”。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这里是“隐秘大脑”。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。
Our minds are complex organs that can process extraordinary amounts of information. Using the superpower, humans have achieved incredible feats. We've harnessed electricity, eradicated diseases, and flown to the moon. But all these accomplishments are largely the creations of experts. Most of us couldn't design a spaceship or a new vaccine. In fact, how many of us even know how a light bulb produces light, or how music is piped into our earbuds, or, as we discussed in a recent episode, how a toilet works.
我们的大脑是复杂的器官，能够处理海量的信息。借助这种超能力，人类取得了不可思议的成就。我们驾驭了电力，根除了疾病，飞上了月球。但所有这些成就很大程度上都是专家的创造。我们大多数人既设计不出宇宙飞行器，也研发不出新的疫苗。事实上，我们中有多少人甚至知道电灯是如何发光的，音乐是如何通过耳机线传到我们耳里的，或者，正如我们在最近一期节目中所讨论的，马桶是如何工作的。
Put another way, we're very smart as a species, but not so smart on our own. At the University of Colorado Boulder, cognitive scientist Phil Fernback says this paradox is at the heart of humanity. We recently talked with Phil in an episode titled, How Much Do We Really Know? Today, we welcome Phil back to answer your questions about knowledge, ignorance, and why the people who are least in are often those who sound the most confident. Phil Furnback, welcome back to Hidden Brain. It's great to be with you again, Shanker. So, Phil, to recap a couple of things from our last conversation,
换句话说，作为一个物种，我们非常聪明，但靠我们自己却没那么聪明。科罗拉多大学博尔德分校的认知科学家菲尔·费恩巴赫表示，这个悖论正是人性的核心所在。我们最近在一期名为《我们究竟了解多少？》的节目中采访了菲尔。今天，我们欢迎菲尔重返节目，来回答你们关于知识、无知以及为什么最无知的人往往听起来最自信的疑问。菲尔·费恩巴赫，欢迎回到“隐秘大脑”。很高兴能再次和你在一起，尚卡尔。那么，菲尔，为了回顾我们上次对话中的几个要点，
one core idea that psychologists like you study is that we think we know more than we do. How so? That's right, Shanker. The illusion of explanatory depth or the illusion of understanding is the very human tendency to feel like we understand things in a lot more depth and complexity than we actually do. To treat the world is much more simple than it actually is.
一个核心观点是，像你这样的心理学家所研究的，即我们认为自己知道的比实际知道的要多。为什么会这样？没，尚卡尔。解释深度的错觉或理解的错觉，是一种非常人类的倾向，即我们会觉得我们对事物的理解比我们实际上的理解要深刻、复杂得多。把世界看得比实际情况简单得多。
And psychologists have conducted a number of experiments to demonstrate this, because of course, if you ask me, do I know how something works? I'm going to tell you, yeah, I'm pretty sure I know how it works. But you and others have run experiments to actually test whether people like me actually know what we think we know. That's exactly right. In a typical study, what you would do, is ask people their sort of initial feeling of how well they understand some object or
心理学家已经进行了许多实验来证明这一点，因为当然，如果你问我，我知道某样东西是如何运作的吗？我会告诉你，是的，我很确定我知道它是如何运作的。但你和其他人做过实验来实际测试像我这样的人是否真的知道我们自以为知道的事情吗？完全正确。在一个典型的研究中，你会做的是，询问人们对他们理解某种物体、
phenomenon or process. Typically, as you just mentioned, what people feel is that they understand it in some depth. But then the trick is you ask them to explain it in detail how it actually works. And what then typically happens is people realize that they don't understand it as well as they had initially thought. Their feeling of understanding decreases, their assessment of how while they understand it decreases. They become a little bit humbled. So a second ago, Phil, you used a phrase the illusion of explanatory depth. And in some ways, this describes the illusion you were just talking about. But can you unpack that phrase for me, please? Sure. This is the sort of jargony way that cognitive scientists talk about this.
现象或过程的程度的初始感受。通常，正如你刚才所提到的，人们感觉他们对它的理解有相当的深度。但随后的窍门是，你要求他们详细解释它是如何实际运作的。接下来通常发生的是，人们意识到他们并没有自己最初想象的那样理解它。他们对理解的感觉减弱了，他们对理解程度的评估也降低了。他们变得有点谦逊了。那么刚才，菲尔，你用了一个短语，解释深度的错觉。在某种程度上，这描述了你刚才谈到的错觉。但是你能为我剖析一下这个短语吗？当然可以。这是认知科学家谈论这个概念时使用的行话式的说法。
Explanatory depth means the depth with which you can explain some phenomenon. And we have an illusion that we can explain things more deeply than we can. So if I ask you about pretty much anything. You mentioned toilets, and we talked about that previously. People feel like they have sort of an annotated plumbing diagram somewhere in their minds, but they don't. So they feel like they can explain it in some depth, and then you say, oh, how does it actually work? And they go, hmm, well, I guess you push the handle down and it flushes. So that's the typical pattern. One of the important points that you and others make is that this illusion is not necessarily a flaw, that in some ways the mind is designed to discard details,
解释深度意味着你能多大深度地解释某种现象。而我们产生了一种错觉，即我们能比实际情况更深刻地解释事物。所以如果我问你几乎任何事情。你提到了马桶，我们之前也讨论过。人们觉得他们脑海中的某个地方有一张带有注释的管道图，但其实并没有。所以他们觉得自己能在一定深度上解释它，然后你说，哦，它到底是怎么运作的？他们就会说，嗯，好吧，我想你把把手往下按，它就冲水了。这就是典型的模式。你和其他人提出的重要观点之一是，这种错觉并不一定是一个缺陷，在某种程度上，大脑的设计就是为了抛弃细节，
that we are generalists, not specialists. Can you talk about this idea? Why is the mind designed in some ways to extract general information about something and to discard the details? That's a really wonderful question, and I think it gets to what cognition is really all about and what it's for.
我们是通才，而不是专才。你能谈谈这个想法吗？为什么大脑在某种程度上被设计成提取关于某事的一般信息而抛弃细节？这是一个非常棒的问题，我认为它触及了认知的真正意义以及它的用途。
Why did we evolve the ability to think? We evolved the ability to think so that we can act more adaptively in our environments. And storing a ton of detailed information isn't necessarily that useful because in the world that we live in, we're faced with very different situations that might have some deep structure in common across different situations, but the details are often different. So what we really need to be able to do is extract the more fundamental principles that allow us
我们为什么进化出了思考的能力？我们进化出思考能力是为了让我们在环境中能够做出更具适应性的行为。而且储存大量详细的信息不一定那么有用，因为在我们生活的世界里，我们面临着非常不同的情况，这些情况在不同的情境下可能有一些共同的深层结构，但细节往往是不同的。所以我们真正需要能够做到的，是提取出那些更基本的原理，让我们能够在
to behave adaptively in new environments. And retaining all of that detailed information might not necessarily help. In other words, if you were a forager, for example, and you were living by your wits and living off the land and you wanted to know what plants to eat and what plants not to eat, you don't actually need to have the deep knowledge of a botanist to understand how different plant species evolved over time and the details of plant cellular structure, you really need only just a few general rules that can keep you healthy and not have you eat something that makes you sick. I think that's right. You know, that's just one area of life. And if you think about trying to maintain a giant database of complex information about every area of your life, it quickly becomes really intractable. And that's why human society has experts in different domains, because one individual can't possibly master everything. That would be futile.
新的环境中做出适应性行为。而保留所有那些详细的信息不一定有帮助。换句话说，如果你是一个觅食者，例如，你靠你的智慧和土地谋生，并且你想知道该吃哪些植物，不该吃哪些植物，你其实不需要具备植物学家的深厚知识去了解不同的植物物种是如何随时间演化的以及植物细胞结构的细节，你真的只需要几条通用的规则，就能保持健康，不吃那些让你生病的东西。我认为是这样的。你知道，这只是生活的一个方面。如果你考虑试着维护一个包含关于你生活各个方面的复杂信息的庞大数据库，它很快就会变得非常难以处理。这就是为什么人类社会在不同领域拥有专家，因为一个人不可能精通一切。那将是徒劳的。
Can you talk about the idea that because we're often embedded in communities of experts, people know things. There's someone in my community who knows a lot more about my toilet than I do, and someone in my community who knows a lot more about house construction than I do, and somebody who knows a lot more about building computers than I do, that in some ways this rubs off on us because we're surrounded by people who know how to do all these things, that adds in some ways to our illusion of knowledge that all this knowledge somehow is ours. That's exactly right. So we live in what we call communities of knowledge,
你能谈谈这样一种观点吗：因为我们经常身处专家群体之中，所以人们懂得很多。我社区里有人比我更懂马桶，有人比我更懂房屋建筑，还有人比我更懂电脑制造，在某种程度上，这会对我们产生影响，因为我们周围都是知道如何做所有这些事情的人，这在某种程度上增加了我们的知识错觉，觉得所有这些知识不知怎么都是我们的。完全正确。所以我们生活在我们所谓的知识社区中，
where the expertise is distributed across the community. And what we found in our studies is that just by virtue of participating in that community of knowledge, we come to feel that we understand things that are actually understood by others in our community. You know, a good example of this is politics. If you think about whatever the complex issue of the day is, when we hear people talking about it,
专业知识分布在整个社区中。我们在研究中发现，仅仅通过参与那个知识社区，我们就会开始觉得我们理解了实际上由我们社区中的其他人所理解的事物。你知道，一个很好的例子就是政治。如果你想想无论当今什么复杂的问题，当我们听到人们谈论它时，
we sort of nod along as if we ourselves understand. And that process of nodding along with our community members, and knowing that the information is out there in other people's minds sort of gives us a little bit of an inflated feeling that we ourselves understand. I'm wondering, Phil, if this might be, you know, in some ways related to what people sometimes call the Google effect, which is that I can Google everything and I can come up with answers to seemingly everything, and therefore I kind of think
我们就会点头称是，好像我们自己也懂一样。这种与社区成员一起点头称是的行为，以及知道信息存在于其他人的大脑中的事实，在某种程度上给了我们一种膨胀的感觉，即我们自己懂了。我在想，菲尔，这是否可能，在某种程度上与人们有时称之为谷歌效应的现象有关，即我可以用谷歌搜索一切，并且我可以想出似乎所有事情的答案，因此我某种程度上认为
I know everything. I think that's right. The fact that we have all of human knowledge in our pockets, it's the most amazing. amazing community of knowledge that's ever existed on planet Earth. And I think that does give us a very strong feeling of understanding and knowledge because we have very easy access to that. Just by virtue of searching the Internet, we come to feel that we understand things better than we do or that we have more knowledge than we do.
我无所不知。我认为是这样的。事实上，我们把全人类的知识都装在口袋里，这是地球上存在过的最令人惊叹的知识社区。我认为这确实给了我们非常强烈的理解感和知识感，因为我们可以非常容易地获取这些知识。仅仅通过在互联网上搜索，我们就会觉得我们比实际情况更懂事物，或者我们拥有的知识比实际更多。
If we subsequently try to perform, take a test, or perform some tasks without the Internet, we actually do worse than we expect. And this has really important consequences. For instance, in education, students who can look things up might actually not master the material and might do poorly on exams and things like that. What I think makes this really interesting and exciting at this moment is with the advent of artificial intelligence, meaning that our search of the internet, it's no longer a Google search. Now it's something, you know, orders of magnitude, more intelligent, more capable.
如果我们随后试图表现，参加测试，或者在没有互联网的情况下执行某些任务，我们的表现实际上比我们预期的要差。这产生了非常重要的后果。例如，在教育中，能够查阅资料的学生实际上可能无法掌握材料，并且在考试等事情上可能会表现糟糕。我认为让这一点在此时此刻变得非常有趣和令人兴奋的是，随着人工智能的出现，这意味着我们对互联网的搜索，不再是谷歌搜索了。现在它是一种，你知道，高出几个数量级、更具智能、更有能力的东西。
And so there has begun to be some really interesting research looking at what the effects are of using AI on people's levels of confidence. And I'm excited to see where that research goes. So we received an email from a listener named Dennis who wrote that in his experience, the more people know about a subject, the more they realize how much they actually do not know. In other words, expertise makes us humble and more likely to recognize the limits of our knowledge. Do you think this intuition is backed up by research film? Absolutely. Dennis makes a beautiful point that has actually been made by some of the greatest minds throughout history. People like Aristotle and Einstein have said similar things. And that's precisely right.
因此，已经有一些非常有趣的研究开始探讨使用人工智能对人们自信心水平的影响。我很高兴看到这项研究会走向何方。我们收到了一位名叫丹尼斯（Dennis）的听众发来的电子邮件，他写道，根据他的经验，人们对一个主题了解得越多，他们就越意识到自己实际上对多少事情一无所知。换句话说，专业知识让我们变得谦逊，并更有可能认识到我们知识的局限性。你认为这种直觉有研究支持吗，菲尔？绝对有。丹尼斯提出了一个精妙的观点，历史上一些最伟大的头脑其实也提出过类似的观点。亚里士多德和爱因斯坦这样的人都说过类似的话。这完全正确。
What happens with expertise is that we develop more of an understanding of the boundaries of a domain. If you are a novice at some task, you might think that there's not that much to know. But as you learn more and more, you realize how much there is to know and how complex things are. So Dennis is absolutely right about that. You know, I'm wondering, therefore, Phil, if experts, in fact, are more aware of what they do not know, whether education in general can serve the same role, that the more we learn, if we go to school, for example, the more we come into contact with the ideas that might be at the boundaries of knowledge. Do you think this might be possible?
专业知识带来的结果是，我们对某个领域的边界有了更多的理解。如果你是某项任务的新手，你可能会认为没有那么多东西需要了解。但随着你学到越来越多的东西，你就会意识到有多少东西需要了解，事情是多么复杂。所以丹尼斯在这点上绝对是正确的。你知道，因此我在想，菲尔，如果专家实际上更清楚他们不知道什么，那么一般教育是否可以起到相同的作用，即我们学得越多，如果我们去学校上学，例如，我们就越有可能接触到可能处于知识边界的想法。你认为这可能吗？
I think to some extent that's correct. The more we learn and the more we realize that how complex and nuanced most things are, that might make us more habitually sort of careful about jumping to really strong conclusions or opinions on issues. That being said, people aren't that great about generalizing their knowledge from one domain to another. So I might learn a little bit about some topic and become more humble about that topic. But then tomorrow, I might jump right back into feeling like I'm an expert on some other topic. That's a very human tendency as well. When we come back, the challenge of engaging with people whose views are strongly held and factually incorrect.
我认为在某种程度上这是正确的。我们学得越多，就越意识到大多数事情是多么复杂和微妙，这可能会让我们在对各种问题仓促得出非常坚定的结论或观点时，习惯性地变得更加谨慎。话虽如此，人们将他们的知识从一个领域推广到另一个领域的能力并不是那么强。所以我可能会了解某个话题的一点皮毛，并对该话题变得更谦逊。但到了明天，我可能又会立刻恢复那种觉得自己是其他某个话题的专家的感觉。这也是一种非常人类的倾向。稍后回来，我们将探讨如何与那些观点根深蒂固且在事实上不正确的人进行交流的挑战。
You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedant. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Cognitive scientist Phil Furnbach studies why we tend to believe we know more than we actually do. It's a pernicious problem that affects many domains of our lives. Phil, can you talk a moment about how the illusion of knowledge can have serious consequences in our lives, everything from airplanes, safety to the well-being of financial markets? I mean, this isn't just fun and games or humorous examples of people believing they know more than they do. This can actually have serious consequences. Absolutely. And that's why I got so interested in this topic, because I realized it's not about
你正在收听的是“隐秘大脑”。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这里是“隐秘大脑”。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。认知科学家菲尔·费恩巴赫研究了为什么我们倾向于相信自己知道的比实际知道的要多。这是一个影响我们生活许多领域的恶性问题。菲尔，你能花点时间谈谈知识错觉如何在我们的生活中产生严重的后果吗？从飞机安全到金融市场的福祉，无所不包。我的意思是，这不仅仅是好玩的游戏或人们自以为比实际知道得多的幽默例子。这实际上会产生严重的后果。绝对是这样。这也是为什么我对这个话题如此感兴趣，因为我意识到这不仅仅关乎
toilets. It's about pretty much everything that we argue about, both as individuals and as a society. If you think about, say, your financial well-being, if you feel super confident about your ability to beat the stock market and you start taking it. on more and more risky bets, you can get yourself into a lot of trouble on a personal level. At a societal level, our core beliefs about policy issues and social issues are what determine the laws that we pass, the decisions we make as a society about how we're going to set up our government, when we're going to go to war. These really kind of important decisions are determined by our strength of belief about whatever the underlying issue is.
马桶。它关乎我们作为个人和作为一个社会所争论的几乎所有事情。如果你想想，比如说你的财务状况，如果你对你击败股市的能力超级自信，并开始承担越来越多的风险投资，你在个人层面上会让自己陷入很多麻烦。在社会层面上，我们对政策问题和社会问题的核心信念决定了我们通过的法律，决定了我们作为一个社会关于如何建立我们的政府、何时参战的决定。这些确实非常重要的决定是由我们对任何潜在问题的信念强度所决定的。
You know, I was talking with a group of doctors some time ago in the Pacific Northwest. And one of them told me that, you know, she has the feeling that when patients come to her, they now come armed with information about the illnesses and problems that they think they have because they have looked up those problems on the Internet. And she was telling me that she often feels like she's a vending machine, that patients are basically coming and they want to press a couple of buttons and get the medicines that they themselves have chosen for themselves before they've even come to see her. She was talking about how dispiriting this is as a doctor and how difficult it is to talk patients off the ledge to basically say, no, you think you have condition A, but in fact, you have something completely different.
你知道，不久前我在太平洋西北部与一群医生交谈。其中一个人告诉我，你知道，她有一种感觉，当病人们来找她时，他们现在都带着关于他们认为自己所患疾病和问题的信息，因为他们在互联网上查阅了这些问题。她告诉我，她经常觉得自己像一台自动售货机，病人们基本上一来就想按几个按钮，在她甚至还没见到他们之前，就拿到他们自己为自己挑选的药物。她谈到作为一名医生，这种感觉是多么令人沮丧，要把病人从边缘劝回来，基本上告诉他们“不，你认为你得的是A病，但实际上你得的是完全不同的病”，是多么困难。
That's a great observation. And in fact, I started a project a few years ago on precisely this. We called it the WebMD effect. And the idea was people were going and Googling their symptoms and doing a few minutes of diagnostic work and then going into the doctor and being super sure that they knew what they were talking about. But, of course, medicine is a highly complex field, and the body behaves in ways that are very hard to predict and understand for someone who doesn't have detailed training and knowledge. And so I very much relate to what your doctor friend was saying. So a moment ago, Phil, you talked about how the illusion of knowledge can apply not just to,
这是一个极好的观察。事实上，几年前我针对这个问题启动了一个项目。我们称之为“网络医学百科效应”（WebMD effect）。这个想法是，人们去谷歌搜索他们的症状，花几分钟做一些诊断工作，然后走进医生办公室，超级确信他们知道自己在谈论什么。但是，当然，医学是一个高度复杂的领域，对于没有接受过详细训练和知识的人来说，人体的表现方式是非常难以预测和理解的。所以我对你的医生朋友所说的话非常有共鸣。那么刚才，菲尔，你谈到了知识错觉不仅适用于
you know, our knowledge about how toilets work or how pens work, but also to our political opinions. We often overestimate how much we know about public policy. and that can lead to heated differences in opinion between people who don't really know what they're talking about. We got a question from a listener named Rob about that issue. Here he is.
我们关于马桶或钢笔如何工作的知识，也适用于我们的政治观点。我们经常高估了自己对公共政策的了解程度。这会导致那些其实并不知道自己在谈论什么的人之间爆发激烈的观点分歧。我们收到了一位名叫罗布（Rob）的听众关于这个问题的提问。我们来听听他的声音。
You suggested that one approach to improving dialogue with people with whom we disagree is to ask questions and be genuinely curious about their positions and how they arrive there. As with those experiments where Phil Frembach exposed the ignorance of those who felt they knew about public policy, how would we avoid making people feel like we're grilling them?
你曾建议，改善与我们不同意见的人的对话的一种方法是提出问题，并对他们的立场以及他们是如何得出这一立场的保持真正的求知欲。正如菲尔·费恩巴赫在那些实验中暴露了那些觉得了解公共政策的人的无知一样，我们如何才能避免让人觉得我们在严刑拷问他们呢？
I'm sure some subjects in his experiments were chagrined to find out that they didn't really know as much as they thought. Surely, there are some tricks about asking questions without making others feel like it's an interrogation. Could you offer any tips on that? So, Phil, in a good faith discussion, we want to be curious about someone and ask them questions, but I can also imagine alienating them if we press too hard. How do we find that balance, Phil? Well, Rob makes a very insightful point. And this is something that I've struggled with and thought about so much over the last 10 years or so. When people are challenged on their knowledge, they may become defensive. And the goal of a dialogue is not to make someone feel stupid or ignorant. So I think that the key when engaging in this kind of dialogue, which I do think can be very productive, is to set some ground rules first. The idea is, I'm not trying to grill you to, to show that you don't know what you're talking about.
我确信他实验中的一些受试者发现自己其实并没有想象中懂得那么多时感到很懊恼。肯定有一些关于提问的技巧，既能提出问题，又不会让别人觉得这是一种审讯。你能提供一些这方面的秘诀吗？所以，菲尔，在真诚的讨论中，我们希望对某人保持好奇并向他们提问，但我也能想象，如果我们逼得太紧，会把他们推远。我们如何找到那种平衡呢，菲尔？嗯，罗布提出了一个非常有洞察力的观点。这也是我在过去十年左右一直苦苦思索和思考的问题。当人们的知识受到质疑时，他们可能会变得具有防御性。而对话的目的不是为了让某人显得愚蠢或无知。所以我认为，在进行这种我确实认为非常富有成效的对话时，关键是要先设定一些基本规则。这个想法是，我不是想审问你，
But I'm acknowledging that I don't know what I'm talking about either, and we're going to work together to interrogate both sides. We're going to interrogate both positions. And then I think both people are in equal footing, and that can be a very productive discourse. I think Rob's insight is exactly right, that if the dialogue is one person interrogating the other and trying to make them feel stupid,
来证明你不知道自己在谈论什么。但我承认我也不知道我在谈论什么，我们将共同努力盘问双方。我们将盘问双方的立场。然后我认为双方都处于同等的地位，这可以成为一个非常富有成效的论述。我认为罗布的洞察力完全正确，如果对话变成一个人审问另一个人并试图让他们觉得自己很愚蠢，
you're not going to get anywhere. Hmm. You know, I was talking to a friend some time ago, and he was pointing out that the Socratic method of, you know, asking a series of questions and having the other person answer them. And then over time, you show the person who was answering the questions didn't know very much about what they were talking. And the idea is that this is eventually how you lead people to enlightenment.
你是不会有任何进展的。嗯。你知道，不久前我和一个朋友交谈，他指出苏格拉底式的提问方法，即提出一系列问题并让对方回答。然后随着时间的推移，你向回答问题的人表明，他们对自己谈论的事情其实并不了解。这个想法是，这最终是如何引导人们走向顿悟的。
My friend was pointing out that this is a really condescending way to have a conversation with someone where you're asking them a lot of questions. And they stick with the conversation even though they slowly get to see that they, in fact, don't know what they're talking about. And so Rob's point, I think, is well taken here because to actually practice this, to actually be curious about someone without coming across as interrogating them or grilling them is not easy to do. That's right. The Socratic method implies that you have a teacher and a student, and the teacher knows the answer and is helping the student to come to their own realization of the answer. In a typical discourse around some public policy issue, both interlocutors aren't going to have all the answers. And so the goal should be a little bit different.
我的朋友指出，这是一种与人对话的非常居高临下的方式，你问了他们很多问题。尽管他们慢慢开始看到他们实际上并不知道自己在谈论什么，但他们还是坚持了对话。因此，我认为罗布的观点在这里是正确的，因为要真正实践这一点，要在不给人审讯或严加拷问的感觉的情况下对某人保持好奇，并不是一件容易的事。确实如此。苏格拉底式的方法暗示你有一个老师和一个学生，老师知道答案并帮助学生自己领悟答案。在围绕某个公共政策问题的典型讨论中，两个对话者不可能拥有所有的答案。所以目标应该略有不同。
So it shouldn't really be a guided interrogation like a Socratic kind of approach where one person is leading. I think it should be more of a jointful approach where both are conversing in this more open-minded questioning way. I think to me that would be more helpful. We got a question from listener Kate, who also asked about how to manage tricky discussions. She said, I struggle with how to manage conversations where the opposing views, is based on facts that are nonsensical. Is there a way to continue when the facts we believe are not the same?
所以它真的不应该像苏格拉底式的方法那样是一种有引导的审讯，由一个人主导。我认为它应该更像是一种共同的方法，双方都以这种更开放的质疑方式进行对话。我认为对我来说这将更有帮助。我们收到了听众凯特（Kate）的问题，她也询问了如何处理棘手的讨论。她说，我很难处理这样的对话：相反的观点是建立在荒谬的事实之上的。当我们的信念所基于的事实不一致时，有没有办法继续下去？
Yeah, Kate raises another really interesting point, which is facts are another place where the world is a lot more complicated than we often give it credit for. We often speak about that something can be true or false. Most complex issues, what goes into a fact or a statistic or whatever it is, there's a lot of background in context that determines what that fact or statistic means.
是的，凯特提出了另一个非常有趣的点，那就是事实是世界比我们通常认为的要复杂得多的另一个地方。我们经常谈论某事可以是真是假。在大多数复杂问题中，构成事实或统计数据或其他什么东西的背后，有很多背景和语境决定了该事实或统计数据的含义。
And so part of the discussion really has to get pretty deep, I think, in terms of understanding exactly what that fact is and what it's predicated based on. I think that most people are generally reasonable, but some people are unreasonable. And if someone is unreasonable and they're unwilling to actually engage in that deeper discussion about what the fact means, and they just want to assert that as true, regardless of anything else, then maybe that's not a great person to have political discussions with. Maybe you should talk about something else. One of the things that Kate mentioned a second ago, Phil, is this idea that she finds it
因此，在理解该事实究竟是什么以及它基于什么进行预测方面，讨论的一部分确实必须变得相当深入。我认为大多数人总体上是讲道理的，但有些人是不讲道理的。如果某人不讲道理，并且不愿意真正参与关于事实含义的更深入讨论，而只是想不管三七二十一断言那是真的，那么这个人可能不是进行政治讨论的绝佳人选。也许你应该谈点别的。凯特刚才提到的事情之一，菲尔，是她发现
difficult to have conversations with people who come up with nonsensical facts. In our earlier conversation, you talked about having a conversation with people who believed that the earth was flat. Talk a moment about whether you found it difficult to have those conversations. At the back of your mind, surely you were thinking it's absurd that where were even having this conversation. How did you maintain a spirit of openness and curiosity as you were talking with people who fervently held this belief? Yeah, the flat earthers are a great example and really fun to talk about because the core overarching belief is preposterous. But what I found when I was at this conference was that it's based on a whole set of knowledge and facts within this community
与提出荒谬事实的人进行对话很困难。在我们之前的对话中，你谈到了与相信地球是平的人进行对话。谈谈你是否觉得进行这些对话很困难。在你的潜意识里，你肯定在想，我们居然还在进行这种对话，真是荒谬。当你与狂热持有这种信念的人交谈时，你是如何保持开放和好奇的精神的？是的，地平说信徒是一个很好的例子，而且和他们谈话非常有趣，因为其核心的总体信念是荒谬的。但我发现在参加这个会议时，它是建立在这个社群内的一整套知识和事实的基础上的，
that are, that they believe they have established. And what you find when you get into this is that individual facts are hard to refute because there's so much that goes into it. And I myself am not an expert, right? I can't tell you what an eclipse should look like from a certain vantage point on the face of the earth or whatever the relevant fact is. That's, that's really difficult for me to do. And so I didn't go in there with a goal of trying to convince those people that they are wrong. I don't think that that's the correct goal in a dialogue most of the time. The goal should be to try to develop a deeper understanding of where the belief comes from. And so I found that to be more productive, asking these people about, oh, why is it that
他们认为这些知识和事实是他们已经确立的。当你深入其中时，你会发现单个事实很难反驳，因为其中涉及的内容太多了。而我自己也不是专家，对吧？我无法告诉你从地球表面的某个特定 vantage point（视角）看日食应该是什么样子的，或者任何相关的事实是什么。那对我们来说真的很困难。所以我去那里的目的不是为了试图说服那些人他们是错的。我认为在大多数时间的对话中，那并不是正确的目的。目标应该是试图对信仰的来源有更深入的理解。所以我发现这样做更有成效，问这些人关于，哦，为什么
you believe this and trying to understand all of the nuance to their position? When we come back, Phil Furnbach shares how we might remedy the illusion of knowledge. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Phil Furnback studies how we often overestimate how much we actually know about a given topic. Along with Stephen Sloan, he is co-author of the knowledge illusion,
你相信这个，并试图理解他们立场的全部细微差别？稍后回来，菲尔·费恩巴赫将分享我们如何能够弥补知识错觉。你正在收听的是“隐秘大脑”。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这里是“隐秘大脑”。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。菲尔·费恩巴赫研究了为什么我们经常高估自己对给定主题的实际了解程度。他和斯蒂芬·斯洛恩（Stephen Sloan）共同合著了《知识的错觉：为什么我们从不孤立思考》。
why we never think alone. Phil, we heard a question from a listener named Rob earlier, and he actually had a second question, I'd like to play for you. This episode seemed to correctly suggest that the majority of people fall on the overconfidence end of the spectrum. I'd like to suggest that you might have a separate discussion about people
菲尔，我们刚才听到了听众罗布提出的一个问题，他其实还有第二个问题，我想放给你听听。这期节目似乎正确地表明，大多数人都属于过度自信的一端。我想建议你可以就光谱另一端的人进行另一场讨论，也就是我们这些每天都在为自己对世界的理解是多么匮乏而挣扎的可怜虫，对于我们这些从物理到烹饪一切都缺乏自信的人来说，这可能是一个相当大的负担。甚至一些有成就的人，比如电影导演和演员，
on the other end of the spectrum, us poor souls who struggle every day with how little we understand the world, this can be quite a burden to those of us who lack confidence about everything from physics to cooking. Even some accomplished people, such as movie directors and actors,
在他们的职业生涯中也曾与自信心作斗争。对这群较小的人群进行讨论，可以很好地补充你对那些过度自信的人的分析。所以，如果过度自信的问题在知识错觉方面是一个严重的问题，菲尔。那么自信不足的问题呢？
have struggled with self-confidence during their careers. A discussion about this smaller group of people might be an interesting compliment to your analysis of those who are overconfident. So if the problem of overconfidence is a serious problem when it comes to the knowledge illusion fail. What about the problem of underconfidence?
是的，罗布在这里提出了另一个非常精彩的观点。我喜欢把智识上的谦逊视为目标。这意味着我们在对某事的理解程度与我们认为自己对该事的理解程度之间有着良好的校准。自信不足可以说是相对于理解错觉的另一个极端。我们的理解感甚至低于它应该达到的水平。这可能对人们的体验同样具有破坏性。此外，人类倾向于喜欢那些自信
Yeah, Rob makes another really wonderful point here. I like to think about intellectual humility as the goal. What that means is that we have calibration between how well we understand something and how well we think we understand that thing. Underconfidence is sort of the other pole relative to the illusion of understanding. our feeling of understanding is even lower than it should be. And that can be equally detrimental to people's experience. Moreover, human beings tend to like people who are confident
并表达自信的人。如果你想想你们组织中的领导者、我们的政治领袖，或者你最喜欢的运动员，他们往往散发出很多自信，甚至可能比实际应有的自信还要多。人们喜欢这样的人并对之做出反应。因此，长期自信不足的人可能会遭受很多痛苦，因为他们没有被置于权力和领导的地位，
and express confidence. If you think about the leaders in your organization or our political leaders, your favorite athlete, they tend to exude a lot of confidence, maybe even more confidence than is warranted. And people like that and they respond to it. So people who are chronically underconfident can suffer a great deal because they're not put into positions of power, leadership,
并表达自信。如果你想想你组织中的领导者、我们的政治领袖或你最喜欢的运动员，他们往往会散发出很大的自信，甚至可能比实际情况更自信。人们喜欢这样，并且对此做出回应。因此，那些长期缺乏自信的人会遭受很大的痛苦，因为他们不会被安排到权力和领导的职位上，
they can lose their self-efficacy and so on. So if you are a person who tends to be chronically underconfident, I think it's really important to appreciate that the world is really complicated. And it's okay not to know everything and to understand everything. And a lot of the people around you who are going around expressing tremendous confidence about whatever it is, it's not because they necessarily have much more mastery than you do in the topic. It might be that their psychology pushes them to be more confident. And so getting comfortable with the fact that we can't know everything and that the world is really
他们可能会失去自我效能感等等。所以，如果你是一个容易长期缺乏自信的人，我认为非常重要的一点是要认识到，这个世界真的很复杂。不知道一切、不理解一切并没有关系。你身边有很多表现出对任何事都极其自信的人，这并不是因为他们在该主题上真的比你掌握了更多的精通度。可能只是他们的心理促使他们表现得更自信。因此，适应我们无法了解一切以及世界真的很
complex, and it's important for us to take positions on issues regardless of that is really critical. So one of the implications of what you're just saying, Phil, is that overconfidence might be bad and underconfidence might be bad, and we have to find that middle path where in some ways our confidence about a subject is calibrated to what we actually know about the subject. Monica from St. Paul has a question that addresses this very issue. How do we right-size our reflection of what we know and what we don't know, and also right-size our reflection of our capabilities and our self-doubt so that we don't descend into imposter syndrome. Thank you.
复杂这一事实，对于我们在不考虑这些的情况下对问题表明立场非常关键。菲尔，你刚才所说的一个含义是，过度自信可能是不好的，自信不足也可能是不好的，我们必须找到那个中间道路，即我们在某种程度上对一个主题的自信程度，与我们对该主题的实际了解相匹配。来自圣保罗的莫妮卡有一个问题正好针对这一点。我们如何适度调整对我们所知和所不知的反映，同时也适度调整对我们能力和自我怀疑的反映，以免陷入冒名顶替综合征？谢谢。
So the tricky thing here, Phil, is that you've told us that our minds are flawed in that our minds tend to make errors in judgment in terms of how much we actually know, but our minds are all we have to actually make judgments about whether our judgments are correct. What do we do? This is a very tricky point. What we're trying to do is act with wisdom or prudence, right? We want to do the best that we can give in the situation. And that determination can be pretty challenging
所以这里棘手的地方在于，菲尔，你告诉过我们，我们的思维是有缺陷的，因为在判断我们实际了解多少方面，我们的思维往往会产生判断错误，但我们的思维又是我们唯一用来判断我们的判断是否正确的工具。我们该怎么办？这是一个非常棘手的问题。我们试图做的是以智慧或审慎行事，对吧？我们希望在当时的情况下做到最好。而这种决心可能相当具有挑战性
because to take a position on an issue, it's just not practical to study it as if you were going to get a PhD in that topic. At the same time, to jump to some really strong opinion based on nothing, based on, you know, having read half of one article or seen one post on Twitter, that's also really bad, right? So what we need to be able to do is find some common ground, some middle path, as you said. And exactly where that middle path lies, that determination is a pretty tricky one. But if we get in the habit of trying to aim for somewhere
因为要对一个问题表明立场，像要获得该主题的博士学位那样去研究它是不切实际的。与此同时，基于一无所知、基于你读了一篇文章的一半或者在推特上看到了一条帖子就得出非常极端的强硬观点，这也是非常糟糕的，对吧？所以我们需要能够做的是找到一些共同点，正如你所说的中间道路。而这条中间道路究竟在哪里，这个决定是一个相当棘手的问题。但如果我们养成习惯，试图瞄准某个地方
in the middle of that distribution, I think that people are pretty reasonable and we can do it. So having a little more discrimination and deliberation than we normally do, but not going so far to think that we need to know everything about a topic or an issue before we have a position on it, somewhere in the middle, you're going to be better off than where you are right now. A listener named Neviot asked whether there are any practical things that we can do that can help us reach this middle path. Here's this question. I was wondering if there is any system or frameworks that one can implement in their everyday life
处在那个分布的中间，我认为人们都挺讲道理的，我们能做到这一点。因此，比平时多一点辨别力和审慎，但不要走到认为在对一个问题或议题表态之前必须了解关于它的全部的地步，折中一下，你会比现在的情况过得更好。一位名叫内维特的听众询问，是否有任何实际的事情可以帮助我们达到这条中间道路。他的问题是这样的：我想知道是否有什么系统或框架可以让人在日常生活中实施
to prevent falling victim to the illusion of knowledge. I'm looking forward to hear from you. Have a great rest of your day. If I understand Neviot correctly, Phil, I think what he's asking is whether there are practical things that we can do, practical questions that we can ask us. that can guide us toward that middle path? I think absolutely, and this is a habit that I've gotten in myself, which is practicing checking your understanding.
以防止陷入知识错觉的受害者。我期待听到你们的回复。祝你们今天剩余时间过得愉快。如果我没理解错的话，菲尔，我想他问的是，是否有我们可以做的实际事情，我们可以问自己哪些实际问题，这些问题能引导我们走向那条中间道路？我认为绝对有，这是我自己已经养成的一个习惯，那就是练习检验你的理解。
Neviot asked if there's a way to stop the illusion. I don't think there's a way to stop the illusion. What I think we can do is we can experience the illusion and then we can mentally calibrate after we've experienced it. So when I jump to a strong position on something, I can habitually ask myself after that to try to explain, to really test whether I know what I'm talking about. And then when you notice that there's a big gap, sort of make a mental note of that. Maybe even write it down and see how many times that's occurring over the course of your day.
内维特问是否有办法阻止这种错觉。我不认为有什么办法可以阻止这种错觉。我认为我们能做的是，我们可以体验这种错觉，然后在体验之后进行心理校准。因此，当我突然对某事产生一个强烈的立场时，我可以习惯性地在事后问自己，试着解释，来真正测试我是否知道自己在谈论什么。然后当你发现有很大的差距时，在心里记下来。甚至可以把它写下来，看看这在你的日常生活中发生了多少次。
And I still, you know, I've been studying this topic for many, many years. And I can promise your listeners that I fault. for this all the time still. But I have gotten better at habitually checking my understanding, and that practice, I do think, has made me more humble about my knowledge overall. I'm wondering, Phil, if the illusion of knowledge is partly domain-specific, and by that I mean, you know, if there's some issue that I care about a lot, let's see I care about a political issue a lot.
而且我仍然，你知道的，我已经研究这个主题很多很多年了。我可以向你的听众保证，我仍然经常犯这个错误。但我已经变得更擅长习惯性地检验我的理解，这种实践，我确实认为这让我对自己的整体知识保持了更多谦逊。菲尔，我想知道知识错觉是否在某种程度上是特定于领域的，我的意思是，你知道的，如果有些问题我很在乎，比方说我很在乎一个政治问题。
It might be that I tell myself that I know a lot about this issue because I care about it deeply. But there might be some other issue or some other technology that I don't really care very much about. It's sort of peripheral to my life. I don't really know very much about it. I don't care very much about it. And if you ask me, how much do you know about, you know, nanotechnology or material science or astrophysics? I might say, well, you know, I really don't know very much. Is it possible that the knowledge illusion in some ways is tied to our own self-concept,
可能是因为我深深地在乎这个问题，所以我告诉自己我对这个问题了解很多。但也可能有一些其他的问题或其他技术，我其实并不是很在乎。它对我的生活来说有点边缘化。我其实对它了解不多。我不是很在乎。如果你问我，你对，你知道的，纳米技术或材料科学或天体物理学了解多少？我可能会说，嗯，你知道的，我其实了解得不多。知识错觉在某种程度上是否与我们的自我概念挂钩，
that the things, there are things we care about, and those are the places precisely where the knowledge illusion rears its head most dramatically? Well, I think the knowledge illusion occurs both for things that we care about and for things we don't care about. I mean, who cares about how a toilet works, right? However, I think your intuition is right that things that we care deeply about, we're more prone to an even stronger illusion. And let me give you an example of that.
有些事情是我们关心的，而恰恰在这些事情上，知识错觉表现得最为剧烈？嗯，我认为知识错觉既发生在我们关心的事情上，也发生在我们不关心的事情上。我的意思是，谁会在乎马桶是怎么工作的，对吧？然而，我认为你的直觉是正确的，对于我们深切关心的事情，我们更容易产生更强的错觉。让我举个例子。
I've done some work looking at the opinions of people who have very strong counter-consensus views about science. so people who are very anti-vaccination or very opposed to genetically modified foods and things like that. And what we find is that the people who have the most passionate strongest views often know the least about the issues. And one reason that could be is because that passionate strong view is backed up by a strong feeling that they understand the issue already. And because they have that strong view and they feel they understand the issue already, it's very hard to reach them with new information. They're not going to look for new information because
我做了一些研究，观察那些对科学持有非常强烈的反对共识观点的人的意见。也就是那些非常反疫苗或非常反对转基因食品之类的人。我们发现，那些拥有最强烈、最坚定观点的人往往对这些问题了解最少。原因之一可能是因为这种充满激情的强烈观点背后，有着一种他们已经理解了该问题的强烈感觉。正因为他们有这种强烈的观点并且觉得他们已经理解了该问题，所以很难用新信息来触及他们。他们不会去寻找新信息，因为
they feel like they already have mastery of the topic. And so I think issues where we feel like we've really studied them and that we care about them a lot, we're going to be even more closed off to new perspectives, different perspectives on those issues. You mentioned that sparking curiosity is a way of fighting the illusion of knowledge. We got an email from a listener named Zach. He writes that he and a colleague are avid cyclists. They go on bicycle tours around the country. And Zach finds that when they roll into a random town, the locals there are often quite curious about them. And Zach and his colleague likewise are curious about the new place they're in. And it
他们觉得自己已经掌握了这个主题。因此，对于那些我们觉得自己真的研究过并且非常关心的问题，我们对关于这些问题的新的视角、不同的视角将更加封闭。你提到激发好奇心是打击知识错觉的一种方式。我们收到了一位名叫扎克的听众发来的电子邮件。他写道，他和一位同事是狂热的骑行者。他们骑自行车在全国各地旅行。扎克发现，当他们骑车进入一个随机的小镇时，那里的当地人往往对他们充满好奇。而扎克和他的同事同样对他们所处的新地方感到好奇，它
opens up a dialogue between them and the people around them. So Zach's question is, are there environmental conditions or circumstances that are more likely to prompt people to what curiosity? That's such an interesting observation from Zach that being in a new environment can prompt this curiosity. I really like that. I don't know, for your listeners who have children, young children, they ask why questions all the time. There's a never-ending string of questions that they'll ask about some topic because the world is endlessly complex as we've been talking about. As we grow, we stop asking those questions so much. We sort of forget about all the complexity in the world that part of that is our brains and our minds sort of
在他们和周围的人之间打开了一扇对话的窗户。所以扎克的问题是，是否存在某些环境条件或情况，更有可能促使人们产生好奇心？扎克这个观察非常有趣，身处新环境中可以激发这种好奇心。我真的很喜欢这样。我不知道，对于你们当中有孩子的听众来说，年幼的孩子，他们一直在问“为什么”的问题。他们会就某个主题提出没完没了的问题，因为正如我们一直在讨论的那样，世界是无穷无尽复杂的。随着我们长大，我们不再问那么多问题了。我们某种程度上忘记了世界上所有的复杂性，部分原因是我们的脑海和思维在某种程度上
protecting us from all that complexity and trying to focus us on what's actually going to improve our lives, be functional for making decisions and all that kind of stuff. What is going to force us into actually asking those why questions? I think it is being in a very novel environment where things seem different, right? So if we're just in our normal environment, we just go along as if everything is explained and we've already done the hard work of thinking through all of the possibilities and complexities. And when we're put into a new environment, it's like we're a child again. Oh, I've never seen that before. That's curious. So these things kind of jump out to us, I think, that need to be explained. And that can probably prompt people to be
保护我们免受所有复杂性的干扰，并试图让我们专注于真正能改善我们生活、对做决定等有功能的事情。是什么迫使我们真正去问那些“为什么”的问题？我认为这就是身处一个非常新颖的环境中，事情看起来与众不同，对吧？所以如果我们只在我们的正常环境中，我们就顺其自然地生活，好像一切都得到了解释，我们已经完成了思考所有可能性和复杂性的艰难工作。而当我们被置于一个新环境中时，就像我们又回到了孩子。哦，我以前从来没见过那个。真好奇。所以这些事情对我们来说似乎很突出，需要被解释。这可能会促使人们
more curious about asking those why questions. I mean, I've noticed that when I'm a tourist, Phil, I'm traveling somewhere. I also don't feel any pressure to know everything about the people around me or the situation around me. I'm open to asking questions because, of course, I've just been there for two and a half
对询问这些“为什么”的问题更加好奇。我的意思是，我注意到当我作为一个游客时，菲尔，我去某个地方旅行。我也没有感到任何压力要去了解我周围的人或我周围的情况。我很乐意提出问题，因为当然，我刚到那里两分半钟。
minutes. I can't be expected to know anything. So in some ways, being in novel environments lifts the pressure off our shoulders to, in some ways, appear smart or to know a lot, because of course, by definition, we don't. I love that idea. We sort of have a license to be dummies,
没人会指望我知道任何事情。所以在某种程度上，身处新环境减轻了我们肩膀上的压力，不需要在某种程度上显得聪明或了解很多，因为根据定义，我们确实不知道。我喜欢这个想法。我们有点获得了一种当笨蛋的许可证，
which can be a very powerful thing because when you're in your profession or in your friend group or whatever it is, you do feel this pressure to be sort of a master of that domain because it's the one that you live in. And when you're thrust into something new, everybody knows you have no idea what's going on. So it sort of frees you up to ask those questions.
这可能是一件非常有力量的事情，因为当你在你的职业生涯中或在你的朋友圈里，无论是什么，你确实感到了压力，要成为那个领域的专家，因为那是你生活的领域。而当你被推到一个新事物中时，每个人都知道你根本不知道发生了什么。所以这某种程度上解放了你去问那些问题。
And that's a very wonderful idea. I like that. Phil Fernback is a cognitive scientist at the University of Colorado Boulder. With Stephen Sloan, he's author of The Knowledge Illusion, Why We Never Think Alone. Phil, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you so much for having me. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Querell,
这是一个非常美妙的想法。我很喜欢。菲尔·费恩巴赫是科罗拉多大学博尔德分校的认知科学家。他和史蒂芬·斯洛恩一起，是《知识的错觉：为什么我们从不独自思考》一书的作者。菲尔，非常感谢今天加入我的节目“隐藏的大脑”。非常感谢邀请我。“隐藏的大脑”由隐藏的大脑传媒制作。我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲-保尔、克里斯汀·王、劳拉·奎雷尔、
Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brains executive editor. Our unsung heroes today are a group of Hidden Brain super fans
瑞安·卡茨、奥秋恩·巴恩斯、安德鲁·查德威克和尼克·伍德伯里。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是“隐藏的大脑”的执行编辑。我们今天的无名英雄是一群“隐藏的大脑”超级粉丝，
who came out on a blisteringly hot day for a meal and conversation with me after our live event in Mesa, Arizona. Lewis and Tracy Basile, Kevin and Amanda Ahern, and Julie Zucchini, it was wonderful to connect with you. We're truly grateful for your support of our work.
他们在我们位于亚利桑那州梅萨的现场活动结束后，顶着酷热的天气出来和我一起用餐和交流。路易斯和特雷西·巴西莱、凯文和阿曼达·阿恩以及朱莉·西基尼，能与你们交流真是太棒了。我们对你们对我们工作的支持表示由衷的感谢。
There's still time to join us for the Hidden Brain live tour. We'll be in Los Angeles on November 22nd and more cities in 2026. For more information and tickets, go to hiddenbrain.org slash tour. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
现在加入我们参加“隐藏的大脑”现场巡演还来得及。我们将于11月22日在洛杉矶，2026年还将在更多城市演出。获取更多信息和门票，请访问 hiddenbrain.org slash tour。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。再见。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。